Hey everybody,
what's up man,
thanks for doing this.
I appreciate it.
Oh,
it's an honor man.
There's so many people that I really
enjoy and respect have been contacting
me about having you on.
So when they found out that I was having
you on Michael Mouse,
everybody,
Ladies and gentlemen,
uh,
and when they were,
when I was saying that you were going to
be on,
when people heard about it,
they get super pumped.
So that's very,
very flattering.
Yeah.
And Dave Smith,
who I love,
very great friend of mine,
he's a great guy.
He was super psyched.
Oh yeah,
sure.
So welcome sir.
Thank you,
Mr. Again,
it's a good time for you to be here to
men.
It seems like we might be going to war
with North Korea,
so,
uh,
your book,
dear reader,
but I held it up.
Yeah,
it was probably an important book for
people that are like,
um,
what exactly is going on over there?
Well,
that's what I wrote it.
So that everything you read in the
press,
this is crap.
Really.
Everything.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
What's,
uh,
what are they getting wrong?
They're getting wrong that uh,
so there was an article a couple of
years ago,
so the example I always used where you
had all these women marching in
Pyongyang,
the capital city and the headlines said,
Kim Juggling's mini skirted robot army,
and you know how,
how they are all,
they're all brainwashed and robots.
It's like they're all hostages.
If someone puts a gun to your mom's
head,
you're going to march.
If someone puts a gun to your head,
you're going to do it.
You need to do to get that kid food.
These are human beings who are in prison
and of course they do crazy silly
things,
wouldn't you?
Of course.
Yeah.
And the press is like,
ah.
It's also like they believe this silly
shit.
You go to school and you're taught
something and if you don't believe it,
you go to a labor camp,
you're going to smile and fucking not.
But it's not a course.
You read the articles and it's just like
liquid.
These stupid people believe.
It's like,
yeah,
no.
You look at these hostages.
Believe yeah.
That's a better way of putting it for
sure.
Do you really think though,
that people aren't aware that some
people aren't aware of it,
of what?
Of,
of what a dictatorship,
a military dictatorship,
essentially.
I have it down to 45 seconds when I did
an interview with an NPR affiliate and
the woman said,
well,
Kim Jong Il,
so very campy figure.
And I said,
well,
that's uhm ill,
that's the one I wrote the book about
the Dad.
And she goes,
he's a very campy figure.
I go,
well,
that's a very unfortunate choice of
words and she wants to kill herself
because it's upon and concentration
camps,
you know,
so I mean if you look at like the
interview,
which got it right because they said
he's an evil killer,
but you look a team of America and they
look at him as this clown figure.
And I always say the joker from Batman
is a clown,
but you're not looking at all the bodies
behind him.
So yeah,
he's silly and a buffoon.
But this buffoon has millions of corpses
to his name.
And you think it's wacky that they're
marching in a parade?
Well yeah,
I mean for,
in team America's defense though,
that's what those guys do and that's
what they did with Saddam Hussein.
Remember they made them the gay lover to
Satan of course.
But I'm saying is I think a lot of
people in the.
I'm talking at the press specifically,
they take that they take a lot of North
Korea at face value.
So why I wrote the book is so like you
can understand what the hell's going on
there because it's all smoke and mirrors
with them.
Well it is one of the most public and
one of the most visible military
dictatorships and still still viable.
Yes.
In 2017,
which is really,
it's,
it's kind of shocking that mean when you
can walk down the street and Los Angeles
and you know,
go to,
you know,
go to starbucks and get a coffee and
everything's free and people,
you know,
there's billboards protesting this and
people talking about that.
And then there's this certain amount of
freedom that we just completely take for
granted.
We think,
well this is what life is like in 2017.
Sure.
It is in Los Angeles,
but in North Korea you might as well be
living a thousand years ago.
A actually what's funny is different
people are living at different times.
When I landed on the plane,
there was an army guy who stopped the
rich lady and he was like from the
fifties and she was from the eighties in
their clothes.
So they have different time periods
overlapping there.
So how's that?
Explain that.
Basically he's in fifties,
Russian gear,
like the soldier.
And he stopped shaving gear.
Yeah,
because they're their Soviet Soviet.
Right.
So they really were like Russia,
that Russia issue or a Russian style.
It's like green and they've got the
gold,
but it looks cheap.
You know what I mean?
That fabric,
it's it.
It doesn't look contemporary.
The cut,
I don't know what it is,
but something about the.
I just look at,
you're like,
this is communist era stuff and he stops
at the airport and it's obviously like
papers please.
And this was within 10 minutes of me
being in the capital and she rolls her
eyes at him,
which I was shocked.
And she goes and she's on her cell phone
and she's like,
and she digs through her purse,
shows him something and he nods and she
keeps going because what's happening now
is wealthy people in North Korea can run
the government and run their way around
the law,
which is great as long as they run a
foul of.
Correct.
But in which case they just get killed.
It depending.
But yeah.
So when you're in power,
like the laws don't apply to you.
It's not that everyone's scared the
cops.
It's when you're,
when you're rich,
you can have a huge black market.
You can bribe your way out of anything.
So how do people get rich in a communist
dictatorship.
So what happened in the nineties when
Kim Jong Il chose to have a famine and
chose to have millions of people starve
rather than lose his hold on power.
They started looking the other way and
all these little markets that popped up,
blue black markets because the
government wasn't providing food
anymore.
So people would go to China and trade
stuff and come back and you know,
they'd get rice and so on and so forth.
So these markets are now the backbone in
many ways of the North Korean economy
and yet the cops can come and hassle
you,
but you got to bribe that cop.
But it just basically works out to
attacks.
Wow.
So these people are essentially running
black markets inside of this communist
dictatorship and just paying off the
cops so they can keep all this going.
It's public,
it's in the town square,
but it's not.
They don't regard themselves as
communist anymore and it's not.
It's much closer.
Many ways to fascism then to Hitler
style,
fascism and communism.
So the,
are they putting their money in a North
Korean bank?
Well that's the trick.
So they used to have like the money
stuffed in mattresses and then North
Korea said,
we're switching currency tomorrow.
You got to switch it out there.
Forty eight hours.
And everyone started going broke.
So the government figures out what the
people do.
Here's something else that goes and
fucks him over every step of the way.
Here's something else that used to
happen.
It used to be if you go to China,
right to escape,
you just bribe the border guard because
he's hungry and then you go to China and
do what you need to do and you come
back,
right.
Let's suppose you're trading and he gets
a cut now they changed it to he can keep
the bribe as long as he arrest you.
So He lets you go and then he comes
back,
he takes all your shit and he keeps his
money and you get in trouble.
Oh Wow.
So they're very smart.
So they did that to discourage bribes
and encourage a wrestle.
Right.
To keep their control.
And do the North Koreans know this now
they stopped trying to bribe these guys.
Look after a few of them,
but I'm rusting.
Well it keeps kind of changing and then
it's all this.
You never know ahead of time.
It's like a drug deal.
Is this guy cool?
Is this guy not cool?
And that's what so much of it is like
know talking between the lines and,
and working with people.
And who do you know and who's close and
it's all these slight of hand kind of
things.
It's just when you see something like
what they're doing is in terms of what
the way the government is running the
country.
It's when you watch it on television,
you.
My feeling is how long can they keep
this up forever,
you think?
Well,
no,
not for much longer than they should
have because here's what happened in the
nineties.
The famine hit right?
And I can explain why I get into my
book.
The UN came to give them food and Kim
Jong Il said,
well if the UN is giving people food,
they're not gonna need the government.
So what they would do is people in the
UN,
we're not allowed to have any Korean
speakers on staff.
So they went to village a on Monday and
they saw healthy people and they went to
village be on Tuesday and then Wednesday
they went back to the first village and
the Koreans are like,
oh,
this is a third village.
They go,
we were just hearing Monday.
And they go,
no,
you weren't.
And it's like,
what are you going to tell them?
And eventually the UN left.
They're like,
fuck this,
we can't help these people.
So they were willing to let the
population on.
So the first village was pretending to
be a new village?
No,
the right,
correct.
Not even pretending it's just obviously
the same village,
but they're lying to their site where
they saying that they were a different
village because that way they're saying
we showed you three towns and
everything's fine.
So it was basically they just put people
there to act and behind the story.
Did you ever see the vice piece when
Shane Smith went to North Korea and they
pretended to have a restaurant?
No.
So he got that wrong in my opinion.
So what the senior talking about is he's
in the hotel and I,
I think I stayed in the same room as him
and that hotel,
it's nicknamed the Alcatraz of fun
because it's on an island in the middle
of the river,
in the middle of young gang.
So they took them to this ballroom and
they are,
you know,
distributing food to all these tables.
But no one's there,
and he asked the waitress,
he goes,
whereas everyone,
and she goes,
they just left what I perceived that to
be and I don't,
I'm not inside her head.
Of course,
in North Korea,
I,
when I was there,
I'm like,
I got to figure out what the rules are
because I was born in the Soviet Union.
You had these little rules to figure out
what works and what does it.
And what it was is you can never
acknowledge anything's wrong because if
you do,
that's complaining and complaining,
criticizing the government.
So if he,
if she had said this,
food's all wasted.
She's making complaint.
Right?
But if she is doing improv and she's
like,
everything's fine,
then the best you can to come up with is
everyone just left this.
Everything's so.
You have to maintain disappearance that
everything's good all the time.
His perception was,
and she's on camera.
Keep that in mind.
Does she know what she's on camera for?
It doesn't.
It doesn't matter if you're a hostage on
camera,
you're going to smile and nod.
Aren't the worst one was Laura Ling,
uh,
she was interviewing this family in the
capital city and she goes,
can Kim Jong Il do anything wrong?
And they pretended that they didn't
understand her and she,
and she's like,
I'm like,
wait a minute,
you're asking a family on camera to
criticize the government,
are you and are you insane?
Yeah.
What is wrong with you woman?
And it's the wrong way to do it.
Yeah.
Shane's perception was that they had set
this place up as a restaurant and it
wasn't really a restaurant because they
don't really have restaurants per se,
and that they were trying to pretend and
put on this air like they were a normal
society and you can just go to the
restaurant and bar some food.
But when he went in there,
he said the whole thing was clearly set
up just for them.
That's I,
I didn't go to that restaurant he went
to.
So I can't speak on that.
They do.
And I went later than him.
They do have restaurants for sure in
Pyongyang.
We went to several.
They're crappy.
Um,
but a lot of the stuff that is for show,
it's pretty easy to tell what's for
showing what isn't.
So if he's saying that this whole thing
was a setup just for him,
that's plausible.
Yeah,
that was what he was thinking.
He was thinking that they were putting
on like a big pr display for him because
when I went,
when you go to the maternity hospital,
a lot of that stuff is clearly for show
because there's computers but they're
not even plugged in maternity hospitals.
Yeah.
They're very proud of their maternity
hospital,
maternity,
paternity to where you have kids.
What's a maternity?
Sorry.
I think Russia now.
So they have computers that aren't even
plugged in.
Right.
Why do they.
So what's,
what's fake about it?
Like the computers are for display
purposes only.
So it's like,
oh,
we go online,
we are advanced,
we have science and you know,
you go into a lab and someone's at a
microscope,
you know,
cutting edge technology,
they don't look up.
It's like listen,
if you're working at a microscope and 20
people walk in the room,
you're just going to glance stuff
instinctively.
So everyone essentially as a hostage
from even from the police down to the
doctors to including the leaders
themselves.
So when these countries liberalized like
Libya and Iraq,
the leaders themselves are killed.
So even if Kim Jong going wanted things
to loosen up,
he's going to get a bullet in him and
with good reason.
So it's a system where everyone is a
prisoner.
Kim Jong Il became a big missed because
he married a woman in secret and then
his dad,
the great leader,
Kim Il Sung was like,
when are you going to get married?
He's like,
student Dad soon.
And then his dad's like,
I found a wife for you.
And he's like,
okay.
So he married a second woman and kept
his first emily and hidden compound.
And that was,
that was that first son who was just
recently killed.
Wow.
And this was the son that was killed by
Kim Jong Aoun because they thought that
they were trying to organize a coup
against him.
Well,
it's not even if they're trying.
So North Korea has a constitution,
which is for display purposes only,
but what really governs the country is
the 10 commandments of Kim Il Sung.
And the 10th commandment is,
I forget what it is,
something there.
It's the revolution shall be continued
through the generations until it's
completed.
Which means only a descendant of Kim Il
Sung can be the leader.
So Kim Jong,
Il had three sons.
The middle one is a sissy,
so he doesn't count.
He's assisted.
Yeah,
they said he's too much like a girl,
like that's all we know about him.
And he's a big Eric Clapton for certain
pit all like this guy,
pictures of this guy.
There's some online.
You sit in their shoes.
Off they left.
So the eldest son was Kim Jong Nam and
the youngest was Kim Jong,
Il and Kim Jong Nam wanted to liberalize
Kim Jong.
Il Said No.
So if Kim Jong UN is going to be
replaced,
the only one who could have replaced him
was his older brother Kim Jong Nam.
So if he's killed,
that's an insurance policy.
Oh.
So he killed him just to make sure that
he wasn't overthrown.
Yeah,
and he killed his sons to right now he
killed his,
his,
his aunt's husband.
Oh Jesus.
But she drove his,
her daughter to suicide.
So there are,
it's game of thrones in humans.
Six,
six,
six stuff.
And they boast about.
I mean when I was doing my research for
the book,
they don't,
they boast about all the shit they do,
like North Korea was recently criticized
by the UN for having concentration camps
and they literally said we don't use
that term so we don't have any.
That was their response.
What are you going to do about it?
Well,
they've got a point.
Yeah.
Case case claims.
If they don't use the point,
they don't use that term.
There you go.
Something different.
Yeah.
So there,
there's so many layers of hell in this
country that it,
it,
you know,
why I like speaking about it is
someone's got to do it and people don't
know what's going on and it's,
it kinda bothers me.
You know,
when you hear people on TV trying to
give their opinion and they don't know
the actual data,
it's so much worse than people think.
Yeah,
there's,
well we have a very peripheral knowledge
of it,
like in terms of like what's put out on
mainstream media.
We know that it's bad,
but we know that it's a dictatorship.
We know that the people are under the
iron thumb.
Right.
But we don't know too much more.
Right?
Right.
So I had to do all the homework and now
you can read this book and now you have
everything you need to know.
And when you went over there,
what,
what year did you go over there?
In 2012.
So Kim John took over in 2011.
Eleven.
So he had already taken over.
Correct.
So what was it?
What was the.
This was like post all the crying and
the streets.
Oh yeah,
the craziness.
Oh yeah.
Did you want to be there for that?
That must've been fascinating to watch
that there's nothing in North Korea
that's not fascinating because when
you're going through the city,
you know,
in the countryside,
everything's there for a reason and
you're looking around,
you're like,
why did they make this like this?
And you're not going to have an answer
because everything is constructed,
you know what I mean?
So you're trying to find analogs between
what's,
what you know to be saying and what they
have.
And sometimes it's not obvious I was,
they showed us,
they took us to this place and they
claim that there's an invisible wall
that we built that separates the Koreas
right.
And you can only see the wall from the
north and this is to keep the Koreas
divided permanently.
I got the brochure and they,
the you,
your little telescope and you're like,
what am I looking at?
Is this a wall?
This is the path isn't mountainside.
And there was a praying mantis there.
And I told my guide,
I go,
Yo,
I thought this was a communist country.
And atheist country wise,
they're praying Mantis,
ha ha.
And she's like,
I have no idea.
We're talking about.
And then I'm like,
okay,
well,
I mean they're not going to call a
praying mantis.
They must have a different word.
So I said,
well,
this reminds me of my favorite fable,
the Fox in the Scorpion,
you know,
the Fox and Scorpion one across the
river.
I thought it was a frog.
It's,
it's either,
right?
So we could do frog and score for foxes
can swim.
That's where the frogs can swim.
Two Scorpion.
Yeah.
So
far.
So the frog says,
uh,
the Scorpion says,
let me hop on your back so I can cross
the river.
And the frog goes,
had I know you won't sting me.
And Scorpion goes,
if I stinky,
we both drowned and halfway through the
Scorpion stings him and says,
the frog goes,
why'd you Stingley road dying?
And the Scorpion goes,
that's my nature.
And I told this to my God and she's
like,
what's a scorpion?
I'm like,
okay.
So I'm like,
it's like the lobster that lives in the
desert,
she has no idea.
I'm like,
I draw it.
She'd never heard of it.
And you think how many times you've
heard of a scorpion from comic books,
from nature shows,
from nature books,
you know,
just logos,
the horoscope,
and it's like holy shit,
like her level of what is known is so
limited that even something as basic as
that is completely foreign to her
because they don't have scorpions in
North Korea,
so you don't need to know about it.
It's just,
it's so fascinating that in the same
time period as the internet and Google,
Uber Satellites,
Ilan mosque,
all the crazy shit that we're
experiencing that these people are
essentially completely isolated.
Yeah.
Other than what,
how many websites is like 18 websites or
something like that?
Very low on their North Korean internet.
Intranet.
Yeah.
Yeah,
right.
Which for folks like intranet is what
corporations and companies use to share
in internal knowledge.
And so they have a system set up like
that and so these people that want to go
quote unquote online,
that's what they're going to get.
They're getting only very few people are
going to have that access also.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
I mean it's terrifying.
It's horrifying and it doesn't seem like
it has a solution,
but it's also amazing and it doesn't
have to be this way.
Well,
what could be done?
I just mean this is being done
intentionally.
Oh,
for sure.
And,
and this is being done methodically.
So when I was doing the research,
it's like,
uh,
the Russian writer,
Iran said something like,
um,
heirs of this magnitude I'd never made
innocently.
So this was a step by step process from
the great leader,
Kim Il Sung and the director Kim Jong
Il,
to slowly close the walls and these
people and to keep it as airtight and as
much like a prison as possible.
It was a very step by step by step over
the decades.
And you,
and you know,
as,
as you read the history,
you could just feel the walls closing
in.
But we were talking recently about the
wailing and the streets when Kim Jong Il
died.
And about how people who did not,
they didn't cry hard enough,
were sentenced to six months of hard
labor.
Right?
So what they have there is,
you know,
people again,
when you think it's just the
dictatorship,
so everyone in North Korea is slotted
into some group,
like your school,
your workplace,
maybe the young workers,
women's,
whatever.
Once a week your whole group has to get
together and you have to stand up and
say what you did wrong and then your
other friends have to get up and
denounce you and say what they saw you
doing wrong and they better have
something to say.
Right.
So everyone is watching each other all
the time.
So it's almost like Aa,
right,
like from hell.
So this has been going on since the
seventies.
So people are like,
why don't they just get together and
revolt?
You can't revolt when everyone around
you is looking to make sure they have
something to tell about you at your
weekly meeting.
It's really kind of brilliant.
It is.
Absolutely.
That's the thing when people like these
people are crazy and stupid,
like this is brilliant.
They have it all worked out and it's
working for them.
Well it's,
it's a conspiracy at the highest level.
Yes.
I mean really is the entire country is a
massive conspiracy.
Yes.
Fucking stunning.
Really,
when you really look at it that way,
that this is how many million people?
A 24 million.
Fucking incredible.
Yeah.
And that they've been put in.
Everyone's like,
they're suicidal,
they've outlasted everybody except for
Cuba.
Then the last one standing and they
gloat about it and they should be
gloating about it.
It's essentially Los Angeles,
but prison,
it's not.
Los Angeles was a prison but larger than
Los Angeles.
Well,
you guys have warm weather.
They have cold weather and they don't
have warm clothes and the population,
so yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
Even just the population size of Los
Angeles and yet everyone's a prisoner.
Everyone's a prison.
Yeah.
Fucking incredible.
So I just want people to keep that in
mind next time they are laughing at one
of these articles or like how stupid
these people are.
It's like you are going to believe
whatever you need to believe in prison.
Well people don't really look into it.
I mean when you see these goofy fucking
haircut,
right.
You know,
and then you know,
there was some sketch recently where he
made everybody get the same haircut.
That's a myth.
It was a sketch comedy sketch,
but it was just there.
It was like,
ah,
yeah,
this is a stupid aircraft.
Whoa.
Oh,
what's Britney spears up to her?
Just going crazy with Jennifer Lopez.
Grow toward.
Were those Kim Kim corridor ocean.
It was a girls and we just move on to
the next ridiculous thing and the reason
he has that haircut is because that's
the haircut that great leader his
grandfather had in the forties.
So He's like,
I'm my grant.
When Kim Jong Il took over in 1994,
his campaign slogan was,
do not expect any change for me.
That was literally on the billboards.
I am the same person as my dad was who
got in trouble recently for having a
Hitler haircut.
There was a story recently,
someone in Europe,
some kid in Europe was kicked
out of something for essentially having
a Hitler haircut,
which is like today,
my friend Moshe,
Moshe Kasher has a Hitler haircut and
he's just a hipster.
Hitler youth had that couple of years
ago.
It's like shaved on the sides and I kind
of have a little bit.
I mean if you lift the top,
grow a little bit more.
Yeah.
But I mean that's a,
that's kind of like what he's rocking.
He's rocking this retro haircut.
Yeah.
And with good reason and we think it's
silly.
You know,
we,
we just hee,
he ha ha.
Right.
But meanwhile we're watching this mass
atrocity go on.
Yes.
Yeah.
And it's funny for me because every time
I talk about it,
everyone I met is still there.
Like everyone I saw on the street,
it's still there.
Every little kid I saw still there,
my guide is still there.
Uh,
who was a very sweet young lady and it
was heartbreaking and I hate being one
of those people who like,
oh,
I went on this trip and it changed my
life,
you know,
like the whole facebook shit.
But it fucks with your head for years
because of being Jewish,
being born in the Soviet Union.
Those were,
this is why I took on this project.
Those are chances for me to have been in
a camp,
you know,
back in the day for sure.
So to see.
My friend is also from Russia.
He goes,
it looks like Russian people,
the architecture and the clothes,
but it's just Asian people in them.
He's like,
it's a total mind.
Fuck.
Well,
it's also fascinating when you consider
the small amount of time between the
concentration camps or the Holocaust and
today,
I mean we look,
I'm almost 50.
I turned 50 in August,
which when I was a child seemed like an
eternity and now as a man is almost 50.
It seems like a just happened.
Well,
the rush.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Which is 50 years ago,
you know,
we're,
we're just out of the Holocaust,
but 50 years ago we're just into the
Vietnam war.
Right,
right.
I mean,
it's so quick.
It's so recent.
I mean,
what we think of as modern,
we think of as like modern civilization.
It's only modern civilization and a
couple of spots.
Right?
And this was the attitude right before
World War One,
remember,
they're like,
we're civilized now.
There's never going to be wars again.
We've got all figured out and then World
War One happens and they're like,
what the fuck just happened when I was a
boy I was living in San Francisco and
um,
it was all like we were right off of
Lombard street is where we lived,
was a really crooked street.
And um,
I remember when the Vietnam War ended,
I remember because I remember thinking,
I don't want to go to war.
I'm glad they figured this out was a
little kid.
I was like,
good,
we're done with war.
Thank God.
And then when I was,
I think I was 21 or 22 thing,
I was 21 when the Gulf War broke out and
I was sitting there with my friend
Jimmy,
my roommate at the time,
we're sitting in our apartment watching
the missiles.
They showed that night vision scene of
the missiles flying and he was like,
Holy Shit Buddy,
we're at fucking war.
And I was like,
this is crazy.
I thought we were done with this.
Oh yeah,
and you mean the second Iraq war?
The first one.
Okay.
Desert Storm.
That was what it was at 89,
eight,
99,
somewhere around that and so I was 2198.
[inaudible] 90?
Yes.
Okay.
Stunning.
To me at the time because I was like,
how is this possible?
This is.
We're still
doing this.
I thought we were done.
I thought we were finished with Vietnam.
I thought we realized like as a culture,
like hey,
this is something we need to evolve
past,
but it's just so recent.
There's so much pro war propaganda.
Like on the one hand you'll hear how bad
war is and then you'll hear the
glorification of FDR and Woodrow Wilson
and like if you look at the end of the
Cold War,
Reagan Thatcher and Gorbachev,
they ended it without a shot.
They fried half the world from this
communist dictatorship and that's almost
like an asterisk and it's like that's
the way to do it.
Like if you want to end a war,
do it peacefully and without the body
count.
I want to avoid the body count.
I don't want the funerals.
I don't want the destroyed buildings and
people just on some level of revel in
that.
Both in the right and the left.
Well,
one thing that's undisputable is that if
you look back a long enough,
we are clearly evolving.
Human beings are across the board pretty
much except for places like North Korea,
like Steven Pinker,
yes.
Yeah.
Perfect example.
What he's talking about is if you go
what anybody's talking about,
if you go back a thousand years ago and
you look at today with it's inarguable
that this is a far safer place to live.
Yes.
Far more inclusive.
People are far more understanding,
compassionate and far more willing to be
open to strangers.
It's a different world,
but like how does anyone get past this?
This is the thing that freaks me out
when it comes to something like North
Korea.
It's like when you have this absolute
power at the top,
like Libya,
like when Walmart Kadafi was killed and
then you get rid of that,
you have this fucking chaos.
Right?
And how does that ever help those people
that lived there?
It's almost like those people that live
there,
those 20 plus million people that live
in North Korea,
it's almost like they can't be fixed.
Like,
Oh,
you're wrong.
That's not what I meant.
I didn't mean like it's impossible,
but I mean it's like they're so
programmed to living in this environment
and they're so under the grip of this
guy.
Right?
If you take that guy out,
don't you think there'll be some kind of
a massive power vacuum that some will
try to fill a.
yes.
That's one concern.
However,
like I've met refugees and they're the
most annoying,
boring teenagers you'd ever hope to
meet,
which is great because I want my goal is
that a wish.
I want these people to be sitting on
lazy boys with their bucket of Kimchi
and the pounder and watching two pounder
like a,
like a beer.
The telomere,
right?
Oh,
and just watching tv like everybody,
everyone else,
like they have the right to just be lazy
assholes.
Like that's all I want for these people
and a lot of times they are very.
They get acclimated pretty easily.
It's a big surprise.
Individuals,
if they leave that environment,
what I'm talking about is the
environment itself.
It's going to be extremely tough
transition because it's been 70 years of
dictatorship and abuse in isolation,
you know,
when you have a country that's
programmed in that way that essentially
has been programmed from birth and I was
reading an article about a kid that was
born in a prison camp escape from camp
14.
Yes,
yes.
Which is horrific,
right?
I mean that is a horrific account of
like the different stages
of physical depletion that the prisoners
would be like.
So like if you're at this stage,
you can be assigned to physical labor
and you get to this point,
you can't do physical labor anymore and
he's drawing pictures of what these
people look like and if you kill
yourself,
your family has to fulfill your quota.
So even death is not an escape from the
North Korean regime is.
It's a fucking stunning.
So what happens?
I mean,
how is there even a conceivable plan?
The only way.
So first of all,
China doesn't want 24 million people who
don't speak Chinese,
who have no skills whatsoever crossing
the two men and Yellow River's
intervention area and setting up camp
there.
That's their concern.
However they started backing down and
that's the greatest possible thing.
So what would happen is household
backing down,
meaning they started standing up to
North Korea.
They've,
they were like refusing to exports.
They sat down with trump and clearly
talked about North Korea.
There's no way trump is running his
mouth without having a plan with them.
I'm sure that's the case.
They were very friendly with Mara Lago.
Um,
so golf.
What's that?
They like golf and hookers don't like
golf somebody because that's the whole
thing.
It's capitalist now had this whole thing
against golf.
This was a big controversy.
Yes,
it's,
it's the,
it's the sport of millionaires.
A,
I say.
Yeah,
but isn't China like a totally different
environment now we're getting off track
though.
I don't want continue less joking
around,
but the point is once that government is
somehow vanished and I have no idea how
that would happen,
you would have to have China,
Russia,
South Korea and Japan and us working
together to kind of have a Marshall Plan
of some kind.
That's the only way that's going to
happen.
And even in a Marshall Plan.
Well,
how do you deal with all those people
and give them meaningful employment and
give them some sort of a new philosophy
or a new culture or new.
Some sort of government.
I don't think it would be that hard
really.
I really don't because it's not.
There's not like there's agent like
this,
the Muslim Brotherhood,
whatever.
These are people who want food,
clothes,
a roof over their heads and
opportunities for their kids.
South Korea who's the same people has
the highest per capita income of any
country in Asia,
which is saying a lot,
so it would just be.
It would not be easy and it would be a
long process,
but I don't think it would be as much of
a shit show as like Libya or Syria or
any of these other places.
That's interesting.
Why do you think it'd be easier?
Because I think once they find out how
much they've been lied to and now they
have like,
look it just go to this office work nine
to five gifts.
They're very hard working because their
slaves.
Right?
So they don't sound like they don't have
a work ethic.
It's not like they're not ambitious,
it's just like they're ambitious gonna
get them nowhere and frankly the ones
who were the most loyal to the regime
were the ones who starved in the
nineties because they thought food's
coming,
food's coming,
and the ones who are shady and who were
like,
I'm going to get fed by any means
necessary.
Who are entrepreneurial?
They're the ones who survived.
When you left that place and you got
back home and you're sitting there and
you're about to put this book together
and you're thinking about this world
that you just escaped from.
Yeah.
What do you.
How does this play out?
Do you,
did you,
did you think like where this goes?
Did you like look at what you saw and
come up with some possible scenarios for
how this eventually plays out?
Well,
I had one quote from either having their
Steinbeck and the quote was,
how did you go bankrupt two ways
gradually and then suddenly,
so it's going to happen overnight.
We're not going to see it coming.
Uh,
I don't.
I think all those countries around North
Korea,
I've agreed it's a problem.
All those country like this is a fucking
nightmare.
And I think just like with the first
world war,
Gulf War,
they would very quickly get together and
be like,
all right,
we can't have this exploding some
nightmare.
Let's work together and figure this shit
out.
I think it'd be a very,
very,
uh,
difficult but not difficult.
Ideological audiologically a plan to
come forward.
It's so fascinating when you compare
them to South Korea,
which is thriving economy.
He makes some of the best electronics in
the world or the best phones and
televisions and you know,
and it's just amazing that they're right
next door to each other and there's such
a consensus internationally that,
that this place is evil.
You know what I mean?
It's not like,
you know,
Libya where these other countries have
their back and you're ran a rock and all
this other stuff with us.
More religious though,
right?
And with this they don't.
No one has their back,
like maybe some weird African countries
they have allies with,
but everyone in that region is like,
all right,
this shit's a nightmare and enough's
enough.
Well,
it's fucking hilarious.
Whenever they try to show some display a
power and they have a launch of like
some missile that shoots 13 feet up in
the air and then explode.
That could be intentional.
You think so?
So they can't back down ever.
Right.
But if you want to back down without
backing down is you make a mistake.
Right.
So it looks like you don't have the
power.
Really.
That's,
that's where I would put my money.
Wow.
That's,
that's some weird fucking multilevel
chest.
They are.
They've been playing multilevel chest
since the forties.
They didn't have,
but they're all about face about showing
like that.
That's one of the things about Korea
will all I know about a South Korea.
I know quite a bit about South Korean
culture and the way I grew up learning
and teaching taekwondo.
So I was around a lot of Koreans and
they're very much about honor and
they're very much about hard work and
they're very much about appearances,
right?
Like the idea of giving up,
like showing a weakness like that
intentionally seems pretty alien.
Well the choice is,
are you.
If trump says if you go forward with
this,
we're going to attack you.
So that's not on the table.
So plan B isn't like,
okay,
we're going to give in plan b would be
to act like you're defying him,
but not actually defining it.
That sounds so ridiculous.
It's fascinating though.
I'm not disagreeing with their shit.
I mean I,
that's where I would put my money
because think about it,
if you are doing these tests,
you're going to be,
you're going to be testing it and
publicly how many times,
like in America you're going to have
some,
you know,
I guess windows crashes,
but people go through this over and
over,
especially when your life is at risk,
right?
So you're going to make damn sure that
it's going to be working before you
announced,
you know,
April 14th.
We're having our big launch,
right,
but aren't they developing this
technology in a vacuum as opposed to
most of the rest of the world?
Like if you're.
You're dealing with United States,
right?
The United States is,
first of all,
we have the internet.
Second of all,
we have some of the very best aerospace
engineers in the world.
The most knowledgeable people in terms
of rocketry and explosions and all that
shit like you're dealing with is
fantastic database of human beings to
draw from,
but they're isolated like wouldn't it
make sense that their stuff kind of
sucks,
but what I'm saying is if it sucks,
they would do the test privately and in
some hidden place until they got the
kinks out.
Then they would publicly do it when
they've got the kinks out.
Why would you publicly show your hand
unless you had a purpose?
While they probably don't have enough
money to run nearly enough tests like
we.
We know that they have done some tests
that we've observed,
but remember there was a.
There was some concern.
They detonated a nuke.
You have nukes 100 percent,
but there was concern that they had
detonated run under,
I believe it was underground.
Yeah,
it was a few years back.
Right.
But my point is we don't know,
and this would be something that would
be up their alley and it would be.
I don't understand why they would
announce something unless they were sure
they could do it because that's really
about face.
It's like,
you know,
here's our big launch and then you turn
on the TV doesn't work.
That's amazing.
I never thought of that.
You might be right,
but it's.
It's fascinating to think about it that
way.
Does anybody share your opinion?
Is this a call?
Yes.
I mean really it's not.
It's not like there's a huge community
of people who understand North Korea,
but this is what people who have watched
the country do share is the consensus
that you can't take shit at face value
ever with them.
Wow,
that's amazing.
That's a really amazing sort of
strategy.
If that really is the case,
it's really very self aware.
Yes.
We'll look at.
Look at La.
Two years ago,
my buddy called me.
They had a,
they had a photo they released if Kim
Jong Il and on his Mac book and behind
him was a map of the US where the nukes
are going to hit,
including Austin.
My friend calls me goes,
are they get a Nuke Austin?
It's like,
listen,
if I'm looking Austin,
why the fuck am I putting this on my
instagram?
Like what are you talking about?
You know?
And of course they didn't Nuke Austin,
Austin,
I don't.
I mean maybe they know how many bullets
are in Texas when they passed the last
place to invade.
Well,
the way they operate like this,
like there's two types of bank robbers,
right?
There's the bank robber comes in,
shoots up the ceiling,
gets diluted,
gets out.
Then there's the bank robber comes in,
shoots up everyone,
and you know,
you deal with the first one when they
were firing their missiles,
they're fragmented the ocean,
they're not firing them into Tokyo or
Seoul.
That's telling,
right?
Yeah.
Well they don't want to get killed right
there.
They want to show that they have metal,
right?
And they want to say,
hey,
we can launch a missile at Los Angeles,
or I sold 10 million people.
I mean,
you can't even.
they're like,
what about nukes?
What about nukes?
I said,
that's on Fox.
The other day.
He goes,
you really nuke smokes.
You care about missiles hitting those
skyscrapers and soul.
Can you even imagine what that would
look like?
It would be like independence day.
It'd be insane.
And it's close.
It's extremely close.
So the missiles would get there in a
matter of minutes,
if not,
if not even lying.
Yeah.
Um,
what do you think about the theory
that's been run back and forth pretty
recently?
That the United States sabotage those
same way they sabotage the Iranian?
That
would be great.
That would be.
I don't know what I'm talking about.
Sap knows.
Okay.
They sabotaged the Iranian nuclear
program with viruses and they're saying
that it could perhaps have been the same
case with North Korea,
that they sabotage the missile program
with some sort of computer environment
that we have.
That also is very plausible.
Would it be hacking or would it be
something along the lines of someone
clandestine selling some sort of,
you know,
technology to them that turns out to be
technology with an embedded virus.
My understanding was it was hacking
hacking.
Allegedly.
Yeah.
But if they have.
Okay.
I'm not sure I understand how they would
do that.
Well,
they are on there.
I mean it's their online of kind of
online.
Right.
So there would be a way to get to it,
especially if China's helping us,
you know,
the,
the ins and outs of international
espionage and politics and sabotage and
all that shit.
It is unbelievably fascinating to me and
I think most people don't even have the
slightest understanding of how deep that
shit go and how hard people like in the
CIA work and the people that are
embedded in these essentially terrorist
organizations like this was one of the
things that came out about trump
revealing to Russia that these laptops
that isis was planning on using laptops
for bombs and in doing so,
he gave them top secret information that
he felt he had the right to declassify
it.
Give it to them.
Well,
he claimed to have clients,
but the people that have I that I've
talked to that have an understanding,
understanding of the intelligence
community,
say that in doing so,
you compromise all the people that
worked very hard to get to the position
to find out that isis was doing this,
so now isis has to take an account of
all the people and some sort of an audit
of all the people that they're in
contact with and then try to figure out
how the fuck this got out and who,
who are the sketchy people or the
questionable people and then puts people
in danger and people have to flee and
apparently they had to.
When trump did that,
they had to alert the intelligence
community like immediately,
and this is one of the reasons why even
though it seems benign to him on a
surface level because he's thinking
about a million different things,
right?
He's thinking about a million different
things all at once and his lack of
understanding about the importance and
significance of top secret clearance
according to the people that have.
I,
I've communicated with is why it's so
dangerous for him to just talk about
this stuff with Russia will also this
whole thing where people are like,
Oh,
who cares about Hillary's server?
It's just like I,
this is the secretary of state.
Are you equal kind of shit.
She's got on there.
Who the hell knows we have a real
problem in this country of being on
teams and we have a real problem in this
country.
People that don't like trump thinking
that hillary would have been a great
president.
It's a real problem because I'm not a
fan of either.
Right?
And I think you as a,
as a human being,
should expect more from someone who
wants to run the free world,
right?
Where I should expect someone.
First of all,
you'd expect someone who you can clearly
tell is going to be honest.
And you can tell that from either one of
them.
You want someone who has principles and
sticks with them.
You can't tell that from either one of
them.
You know,
it's not what we need.
We need something greater.
And I think there's a great article and
motherboard today,
uh,
about,
it's essentially something that I've
been saying for years that the United
States is far too complicated to be run
by a president and that the idea is
antiquated.
It was an idea that was created back
when people came over here on boats.
Well,
I had an article for the observer and
article called the case for American
succession.
And the point I made was a,
we've had two culture since the
beginning and I agree with you
completely to have one guy running
everything or one woman is nuts.
Well,
what's thought to break stuff up when he
fired comey that woke a lot of people
up.
It's like,
well,
you could just do that.
You just fire the guy who's in charge of
investigating him.
Right?
How the fuck does that work?
I think it was also because Columbia,
six,
eight.
Yeah.
He's a giant dude.
And I,
I,
I can tell him what's that evening that
bothered him.
He tell you,
telling me that trump doesn't like
looking up to someone no way.
Well,
if the guy was totally down for him and
hugged him back and told him that,
listen,
don't worry about it.
Your boyfriend's physically,
he can look it up saying that if clint,
but if,
if Comi was like totally on board at a
total trumpkins,
if he came in and just acquiesce asked,
you don't think that he'd still be on.
He's still beyond,
but trump didn't like it.
He'd make him be sitting when he walks
in a room with some shit.
I mean he's a very petty person,
which is what I admired about him.
I was listening to Sam Harris podcast
recently where they were,
he was talking with two political
experts.
I forget their names,
but two women who were talking about the
case for succession succession or excuse
me,
the k,
the case for impeachment,
and they were essentially saying that
his attention span is so short that they
have to give them visual aids and they
have to put his name as many times as
they came in and memos because he
searches for his name when he goes and
reads from Amazon.
I don't know if that's true.
I mean,
I don't know if that's maybe some sneaky
way of getting under his skin to get him
to go fucking crazy,
which like you're talking about
multilevel chest with North Korea doing
that thing.
I would feel like if that's the way to
fuck with the guy,
it's still leak shit like this out and
to say things like this,
like he needs visual aids or he needs
his name research funny.
So he could rather his name mentioned
multiple times and these memos.
So he looks for his name.
Well,
there's me.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
I think people are so willing to believe
the worst about people that they hate,
that it gets cartoonish.
I remember during the two thousands
where some journalists said,
I don't think George w dot Bush can read
me like a healthy happy,
and it's like he went to Harvard and
Yale.
Come on.
Well,
I don't hate trump.
I don't.
A lot of people think that it's a,
it's a good thing to hate him.
I hate him as president.
I don't hate him as a person.
I don't,
I don't hate him.
I don't know,
doing this country a great service by
making them suspicious of our democratic
process that I've been making this
argument for a couple of years on,
on
on many different shows that it's very
healthy for people to be like,
if this is the outcome,
you need to double check that this is
the system you love.
He's the monkey wrench in the gears of
the model t.
yeah,
and we don't need a model t anymore.
The Tesla,
right?
This is 2017,
something far more advanced and what we
can't just keep patching up the model to
its current year.
Yeah.
We don't want windows 95 with all the
upgrades for 2017.
You get the fuck Outta here right now.
Ninety five to have politics divided
geographically is a very outdated way of
looking at the.
Yeah,
and also to have representative
governments very outdated.
We don't need someone to represent us
anymore.
We can communicate instantaneously.
Right.
Everyone has a communication device
essentially.
Everyone except for.
You're a crazy fucker.
He doesn't even use a phone anymore,
but everyone else is using modern cell
phones where you could tweet for or you
could,
you could vote from anywhere in the
world essentially.
Right?
That's how it should be.
Yes,
we should have technology and we should
have a government.
I mean we should have rather a
government that recognizes the current
technology and utilize it to get the
voice of the people out there.
Well,
the,
the technology is what's actually making
the government put in its place and it's
going at an increasingly fast rates and
integrative and it's also,
what I'm fascinated by is all these
trolls.
Now.
I'm a professional.
I'm writing a book about this on trolls
and the new,
right?
Yeah.
Well the new.
Well,
it's not just the new,
right?
I mean you can call them the new right,
but they could easily be left.
What I'm fascinated by is these people
that they.
They belong to a group and they are in
an identity group.
Yeah,
and that's what it is.
You're telling me that green frog is
outright.
No,
man.
That's people having a good time to
chat.
Held chapter with this.
There's a group online on twitter who
were yelling at me to shout them out.
What are they called?
I'm not going to say it because I said,
well,
tell me what the.
Write it down.
I'll shout them out.
No,
no,
hold on.
I said,
you got Admin facebook,
so I know your real name.
I'm not shouting at somebody.
Turns out to be a mass murderer and he
wouldn't do it.
I'm like,
you're not getting a shout out,
but he's a whole group as a whole group
of Ms. Murder.
Well,
just the one guy like,
shout out our leader.
I'm like,
you gotta give me your name while you
can have a leader.
Boys.
I'm not shouting you out.
If you have a leader.
There shouldn't be any leaders.
I don't think we should have leaders
anymore.
I really don't.
I think there's 350 million people in
this country and the idea of leaders is
some old school alpha chimp.
Bullshit to say right here.
That's the very first sentence in my
book.
Wow.
When the world leader or leadership
returns to currently.
Yeah,
man,
you're,
you're.
You're essentially saying exactly that
relapse into barbarism.
That's a great word.
Yeah.
Barbarism is a great word.
It is.
Mussolini was.
It'll do it.
Yeah.
He was the leader and this was patterson
from what was 1943?
Yeah.
Well,
I think they recognized it back then and
they,
you know,
it's escalated and compounded since then
because society has gotten more
complicated.
We've gotten more diverse ideologically
at remember in the eighties where every
hack comedian would make a joke about
how this diet coke and caffeine free
coke and all these other cooks.
It's like we still have two choices or
politics.
Why?
Yeah,
I know.
Isn't that amazing?
That was in the 19 eighties.
Yeah.
We had 100 different kinds of cokes and
coke.
New Coke was terrible.
He doesn't read.
He's too young.
Jamie's very erudite,
man.
You ever knew coach Jimmy?
He knows things that from coke classic
to the new coke.
Did you ever.
Were you aware of Pepsi Spice?
Isn't that knew my friend Brian single
handedly might have nuked Pepsi Spice
Back.
Is it Pepsi fires now?
Does he?
Um.
I wonder if Brian still has that
website.
He had a website.
He bought Pepsi Spice Dot Com.
It was fucking hilarious.
It's one of his best roles like and he
started writing about how he was on a
diet of drinking only Pepsi spice and so
and as time went on he started getting
sicker and sicker and his diary and he
talking about like shitting out blood
and maybe I should go to the hospital
and Pepsi Spices fucking freaking out
and try to figure out like who is this
guy?
How did he get Pepsi?
[inaudible] DOT com.
He bought Pepsi [inaudible] Dot Com.
Like the moment it came out.
Well two things.
First of all,
if you go read the reviews for sugar
free gummy bears on Amazon,
it's the whole.
It's the similar.
Same thing.
Yeah.
I own cadbury,
creme [inaudible] dot com and I guess I
should do.
I do.
I should do something with it.
Why don't,
why don't you sell it to cadbury creme
eggs while we give you a million bucks.
They got my email,
they holler at mic is right here,
and I also will throw in fucktard's dot
org for free.
Whew.
That's worth trying to hide it.
Pepsi is,
if you Google it,
it will expire at some vending machine.
Oh,
they're trying to spice instead.
It's autocorrecting for you incorrectly.
See that did the second thing.
There you go.
Brian redbands.
Pepsin spice challenge.
Hoax is one of the funniest things.
Ign.
Go Click on that.
On Iga.
Yeah.
Holidays.
And he did this and I want to say he did
this in like 2004 is when I came here.
That's what I was going to say.
It was one of his best trolls ever.
Beautiful.
Yeah,
he came for days too.
He kept updating
still there?
Yes.
Still Drinking Pepsi.
Spiced.blogspot.com.
Oh,
that's amazing.
And it's 2004.
Yeah.
My friend,
uh,
he,
he gave me the idea for this book just
an ass.
She invented Bacon is Bacon,
salt,
all these bacon products.
And taco bell had a line of like Tacos
with Bacon in.
It was like a special promotion.
So he made a Taco out of Bacon,
the shell was baking like a week and he
goes,
you're a Taco bell corporate meeting
because this is on their big launch and
they're just like a thank you for your
appreciation of.
They can't be like that.
You're not the devil.
That's crazy though.
How were they getting all that bacon?
That's what you really want to see this
fucking warehouse full of tortured pit.
Um,
I don't know.
We got way off track here yet,
but what we're saying essentially before
we got onto this crazy rant is that we
need an updated form of government,
you know,
and we needed an updated form of
government with qualified people.
Neil degrasse Tyson had an amazing tweet
the other day I think is really
important.
He was talking about members of
Congress,
I believe it was.
And he was saying,
look at all these people in government
and what are their occupations?
Lawyer,
lawyer,
lawyer.
He's like,
where the engineers were.
The scientists were the math petition.
That's a,
that's a dangerous road because the rest
of life communists said there were
scientific,
scientific socialism and those engineers
are the ones who regard human beings as
factors to be thrown into equation and
that's when you get the meat grinder.
Jesus Christ.
So you.
St Sciences,
Philip Meat Grinders.
I was saying when scientists try to
become politicians,
they start,
stop looking at human beings as human
beings and start looking at them as
factors in the machine.
Yeah,
it's very sick.
Have you been paying attention to what's
going on with Bill Nye?
Scientists are all going after bill.
Neither Mr Guy the Weimer.
Yeah.
What's.
Why?
Why are Germany is right before Hitler
was El decadent and like everyone's just
completely loose and cultural liberal
and he's having these dancers about
talking about their vagina.
It's why motor.
That was what was ridiculous.
Not even a scientist.
No,
he's not.
Yeah,
it tastes.
He's a con man.
Isn't he an engineer?
Yeah,
but he's not a climatologist.
He's not a scientist and he's also
changing his tune.
There was A.
Steven crowder did a bit about it where
he showed the original show that he did
many years ago where they talked about
how gender is from chromosomes,
there's double x,
which is men and or women in x,
y,
which was men and they are establishing
like what causes your gender?
Right,
and now he's completely gone off of that
and his new thing had this woman who
belonged in some fucking Venice theater
group,
like barking out at a poetry slam,
some unbelievably God awful song and
this motherfucker put it on Netflix and
a science show about gender and he
pretended to be like a,
a Dj in the background.
Like this is so not science,
right?
It's not scientific consulting.
Progressivism is just Christianity
without the mythology.
So it's.
It's very much this kind of Christian
ideal,
radical progressive as correct.
Which evangelical progressive is
specifically.
I don't mean someone who like believes
in welfare.
I mean there's this ideology that he's
fallen into.
What's a complete religion which has
completely divorced from reality and
stuff like this.
It's full left wing.
I mean,
I think there's.
There's great ideas and being
progressive,
there's some amazing ideas in terms of
inclusiveness,
in terms of live and let live,
letting people be whoever they want,
express yourselves in any way that you
can see fit as long as it's not hurting
others,
but that stuff is aggressively
propaganda.
It's meant to be propaganda.
What is it?
His show?
His show is.
Yes.
I think what he's doing is licking his
finger,
finding out which way the wind is
blowing and giving into those people.
Now.
I think he's a true believer because you
have to be a true believer to put
something like that out under your name
and think this is a good idea.
It's just a quick.
It's like Christian rock.
I think it's debatable.
I honestly think that these people,
especially a guy like him who was
experiencing life in the public eye
fairly late in life,
right?
And you know,
and he,
when he,
when it comes to people that are really
enthusiastic about science and really
enthusiastic about these ideas that he's
trying to push on the show other than
this gender thing you're dealing with,
uh,
the great majority of them are liberal
white majority and I'm sure he
encounters a tremendous amount of
pressure to be inclusive.
And gender is the hot topic when it
comes to like weird science as it were.
Like trying to figure out like how much
of this is what people feel.
How much of this can be explained in
genetics?
How much of this can be explained with
sociology,
how much of it is nature,
how much of it is nurture,
right?
It's a very complex stew of human beings
and we know for a fact that people very
broadly,
yes,
we have a,
there's a wide spectrum of human
behavior and likes and needs and
feelings and,
and all sorts of weird dysmorphia is
right.
We don't know why people behave the way
they behave.
So for him to like boil it down to like
one of the shittiest rap songs the world
has ever known.
Right.
It's an insult.
But I think that's my point is that I
think you have to kind of drank the
Koolaid to be putting this out as your
product.
Um,
I,
maybe I'm less cynical than you.
I don't know.
That could be it.
I feel like he's had been influenced by
real.
Well,
I think the people that are super
progressive are far more likely to push
these ideas in a very enthusiastic way
than people who are more conservative in
these matters.
They're not going to even approach them
about this.
Right.
You know,
so I feel like he's just been influenced
by the influencers.
Well certainly is getting rewarded for
it.
And once you get rewarded for something,
your brain gets a feedback loop and it's
trying to.
It's kind of self validating.
So that could be it.
I can't speak.
Here's the,
here's the challenge.
I always have two people who always
talked about climate change.
If you can't name two types of clouds
and what they look like,
you don't know enough about science and
climate to open your mouth and that's
him and he's probably an exception.
He probably knows about clouds,
but I'm saying the average person who
reads the New Yorker and they will tell
you,
every scientist agrees that climate
change.
You don't know the names of one
scientist who advised on climate change.
So shut the fuck up.
It's a mantra.
It's a mantra that people say,
well,
this is,
uh,
the,
the scientists degree.
Go for it.
Yeah.
I'm not disagreeing with it at all,
but I am agreeing with what you're
saying.
I totally disagree with it because the
site with climate change,
uh,
with this,
perception of climate change,
because if we had immediate or coming
toward the earth,
that is going to destroy a life.
We're not going to be sitting here
talking about North Korea.
We're talking about,
hey,
what about the media?
Or are they doing something with this
fucking media or the climate change
supposedly is going to decimate all
civilization within a hundred years.
Why are we talking about healthcare?
Why are we talking about China and trump
spelling and his name?
No.
All you're going to be talking about is
the government's going to shut down
until we have an answer to this and
every politician who has children and
grandchildren is going to be like,
we gotta fucking get together and solve
this problem and the fact that this
isn't happening is telling me that
there's more to the story than we're
being led to believe.
How so?
Because the fact that we're talking
about other things.
If this is really this imminent
existential crisis,
how are we talking
about anything else ever because it's
imminent in terms of maybe 50 years that
people are 49,
how am I gonna I'm not even going to be
here in 50 years was fuck you want to
say thank you to the media or is it
gonna hit America and the world.
In 50 years we wouldn't be doing
everything possible immediately to stop
it.
I think there are plenty of people that
would just do coke and fly jets.
I'm not necessarily sure they test all
of their energy to save people that not
even gonna be around to watch.
Sure.
But I think there's certainly 90 percent
of people in Congress,
uh,
90 percent of people in industry care
enough about their children that this
would be the only issue ever.
Yes.
If they felt like it was absolutely
missing and eminent,
I don't think they do.
I feel like yours is so far away.
You can't feel it.
I don't think that's true.
I think for,
especially when you get older,
when you get older,
you start thinking longterm.
Why is trump backed away?
He accent because he's trump is one data
point and he's a living.
I know,
but there's a lot of those lunatics with
tremendous amount of resources that
aren't thinking about the future.
He's rolling back the EPA regulations.
He's trying to fucking frack everywhere.
What he's doing is he's like,
he's the guy who was doing coke and
flying the jet wire,
but look how much opposition there is to
him.
Right?
So the point is,
if this was a real thing,
there wouldn't be opposition.
It would be complete unanimous.
Unanimity,
well there's a lot of opposition because
he is air quotes the one percent,
which means 99 percent are going to be
opposed to the behavior of this one
person who's got billions of dollars and
also has the power to do all this crazy
shit like roll back the EPA regulations
like somehow or another this fucking
lunatic got into control of
Environmental Protection Agency
regulations.
I mean it's pretty fucking bizarre.
So that's why this guy is not doing
anything.
He's.
He is the radical thing that we're
worried about.
But as you said earlier,
I think he's a good thing and that he's
exposing how bizarrely flawed the system
is that we are trying to patch up window
17,
76,
right?
I mean that's really what we're doing.
Seventy,
89,
70,
76.
We had the artists have federation.
17.
80 nine was the formation of the United
States.
Does the constitution.
Why do we always celebrate spirit of 76?
Because that's the American war.
So we were doing independent station.
Yeah,
their commission.
Yeah.
As far as I'm concerned,
that's it.
That's when it starts.
80 nine is when the United States was
officially found.
Was was the.
Yeah,
but here's the thing.
If the constitution was illegal,
you know,
they went in,
in the secret couple of people have
talked about the founding fathers.
They went into Philadelphia secretly.
They said,
you're not allowed to throw out there.
I was at confederation.
They look at each other.
Go with throwing the shit in the
garbage,
right?
That.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Sworn to secrecy,
which they did not have the power to do.
Martin Luther went out and told everyone
goes,
oh,
this is a coo.
And it was.
It was illegal and everyone's still
champions them like there,
this was all this great,
great thing.
This was a complete crew and all that
saying that's a bad thing,
but it was a cool in terms of like.
So who was in control back then?
You mean?
England?
Between England and the constitution
with the articles of confederation.
So the founding fathers in that
convention had the ability legally to
edit the articles of confederation.
The first thing that they were like,
yeah,
fuck this thing.
We were totally throwing out the window
despite our mandate and and we're
supporting each other to secrecy.
Oh Wow.
That's fascinating.
Yeah.
Well,
that's what we need.
I need that today.
I need someone to fucking go.
This is ridiculous.
We're going to throw this whole thing.
I think that was the big percentage of
the trump vote was this shit's
ridiculous.
Yes,
I think you're right.
But now it's even more ridiculous,
which is weird.
Well,
first of all,
a lot of people who were into the idea
that America is going to look after
America and that we're all this foreign
interventionalism,
which is interrupting our lives and
becoming a huge problem.
And then what does he do?
Bomb Syria,
drops them all APP bomb.
It starts.
He's over in Saudi Arabia right now
holding onto a big glowing ball with
some dude is dressed like a wizard about
Saudi Arabia and the Moab.
Who'd you hear it from?
A Jim Norton.
Now I don't remember who I want to say.
Alex Jones for comedic purposes.
Um,
those were two moves to show North Korea
that he's not joking because the Syria
thing went against everything.
He was saying,
the whole campaign,
Afghanistan,
where the fuck that come from,
and then the next week they're all
saying we're not messing around with
you.
North Korea at the time for talk is
over.
So that's one theory.
I heard that the moab bomb was just to
show that they're capable of dropping
that and that they're willing to drop it
dropped in the middle of nowhere.
I think about it.
If you're going to show,
do a show of force when you just throw
it in Afghanistan rather than in
Pyongyang.
Yeah.
That is the move.
I guess.
It's so fascinating to me that we have
nukes and we'd like to ask too much.
We're just get drop the biggest
conventional bond known to man won't
drop any nukes,
so that's fine.
We're cool.
We're cool with that.
Like if he just decided that would be
really fucked up if he just decided to
drop a nuke on isis.
If he knew that there was this place
where Isis is,
isis is 50,000 of 'em all concentrated
in this one area
and
we just saw this fucking mushroom cloud
like that one mushroom.
I mean there's this classic ones from
the 19 fifties when they did those
nuclear autodesk,
but if we saw one of those in the news
over and full color.
Oh yeah.
Oh my God.
From every angle.
You have the camera phones.
People from the space station filming
the fucking.
Yeah.
You could probably see that from space.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Fuck.
Yeah.
And you can see the wall of China.
You can see that.
I think that's a myth,
isn't it?
Think it isn't matter.
Yeah.
Unfortunately I think you can see it
from certain satellites.
Right?
You can't see a different.
It's like how high do you get up to 400
miles probably,
but not like the Hemi v eight.
Yeah.
It's 22,000 miles away.
Detail about that one now.
Yeah,
he did it right.
He did a c space that either from a jet.
Um,
I wonder like what it would take for
trump to want to drop a nuke in like a
select location because I feel like
there's ever a president that'd be
willing to drop a nuke in the right
spot.
He'd be the guy.
You don't think they put a bullet in him
first.
I don't see enough resistance to him
currently.
You don't know who's around him though?
The secret service or if he's going to
nuke Russia,
I can see them being like executive
decision.
I'm shooting this guy.
Damn,
that would be the end of their life
though.
Some of them not necessarily.
It was someone shot at the president
because he was about to drop a nuke
guarantee.
You someone will shoot the guy who shot
the president.
I,
unless there's some kind of protocol in
place that if this guy goes completely
nuts,
what do we do then?
You know what's really fucked me up,
man?
I'm house of cards.
Oh yeah.
I watched that show.
The same thing from a comedic
perspective.
Oh,
the new season's coming out like next
week.
Yeah,
just a masterpiece.
Just finished.
We,
me and the missus binge watched the
entire series and three fourths,
four seasons,
right?
The course of a couple months.
Oh Wow.
Fucking awesome.
If you haven't seen it,
ladies and gentlemen,
it's a masterpiece.
It's maybe one of the best shows ever on
television and it gets.
It starts out you like.
It was pretty good and then it gets
deeper and deeper and crazier and
crazier and there's never what I call a
cut the shit scene like in every show in
season three when she's in Russia and
she feels bad for the gay kid.
That's a cut.
The Shit.
This woman is a sociopath.
She's not losing control and power just
to some gay rushed and she met the dude
who hangs himself.
Spoiler alert.
I don't know.
I felt like that was as much political
as it was anything else,
but they showed her really caring.
You know,
I got to know these people are murderers
perhaps you're a bit cynical.
Little on me.
Pretty bad.
And the Steve Irwin Boomerang hard.
The late Steve Irwin.
Is he a boomerang thrower?
I thought it was just like wrestling
crocodiles and showed us how to do that
shit.
I'd probably got less.
Everybody knows how to write.
Yeah,
just chuck them.
I mean,
is there a technique to throw a
boomerang?
Oh yeah,
of course.
Right?
Yeah.
Because they had.
It was weapons to knock things out.
What was the idea was that you would
throw it and then it would kind of come
back at you if you missed.
Right,
but which is funny because if you
actually have good aim,
it's not coming back because it's
trajectories.
Complete change,
but you're knocking things out of trees
or knocking birds out.
I mean the great way to get a bee hive
off a tree.
Oh,
is that what they use them for?
Right.
I'm guessing.
I don't fucking know.
It kind of makes sense.
Right?
What?
It's kind of an ingenious device.
When you think about what a boomerang.
You remember when you were a kid the
first time you saw one or played with
and you're like,
oh my God,
this is magic.
I maybe only played with one once or
twice in my whole life when I was a kid
I had one and I couldn't get it to work,
but I got to the kind of work and I'm
like,
this is the.
This is the future.
This is a gay for his book.
This is
all due respect to my gay friends at the
MSI friends.
I'm like,
this is just to make any sense.
I don't get what you're doing here.
I don't have any.
It's.
It was like a weapon when it wasn't for
war though,
right?
Was for hunting?
Yeah,
I think so.
It's like,
don't you guys know about the bone
marrow?
We'll hook you guys up.
Lack of birds over in Australia.
They didn't have enough feathers and
like what do we do with these sticks?
But what about the Kookaburra lot of
that.
The Kookaburra Kookaburra.
It's their big bird.
That's always laughing Baja about moves,
right?
Don't they have feathers?
Are you most at as one of them is in
Australia.
There's the ostrich.
The email in the Ria.
I guess the Amazon Australia have huge
feathers.
Yeah.
You feel like it could be trimmed down
for flushings?
Oh yeah.
I didn't know any better.
Did you see that recent thing where they
said that the most,
uh,
the,
they found that the earliest
Australians,
the earliest indigenous people landed in
Australia 50,000 years ago,
which is fucking incredible.
Oh yeah.
Like how the hell they get their 50,000
years ago.
Well,
I mean,
didn't they?
I didn't.
Same thing with like Siberia and the
Bering Strait.
Right.
Getting to America as the question,
was there some sort of a landmass that
connected them to somewhere else 50,000
years ago?
I mean,
they're essentially an isolated
continent.
Right?
Right.
Nothing's close unless you have those
archipelagos something New Zealand and
Papua New Guinea.
Well,
those people,
especially,
especially the South Pacific people were
incredibly daring in their journeys out
to see thousands and thousands of years
ago.
We dug out canoes and these boats that
they would construct and they would just
fucking get out in the ocean.
Like,
let's see what happens.
They must have been having really bad
marriages to be getting this belt.
Bitch.
I'm going west.
I don't care if there's land,
I'm not staying here with you.
Yeah.
What?
What makes a person get into a boat
thousands of years ago and looking out
into the ocean.
Go,
I'm going to take a chance.
And the funny thing is we think that
they're brave,
but maybe they just really dumb and like
a bad directions.
Right?
Who knows?
Who knows what causes someone to want to
do.
And then you get to a continent and
you're like,
what the fuck do I do now?
I guess this is my house now.
Well,
how about what they did with Hawaii?
I mean they essentially found a fucking
volcano.
Just got lucky.
Yeah.
Volcano popping out of the middle of the
ocean.
Yeah.
We lucked out that we fly.
Fuck yeah,
they did.
And then there's the people that don't
look at so much.
Very few bugs.
No predators.
Like,
dude,
I thought that's huge bugs.
It's not.
I don't think so.
They don't have snakes.
I know that they don't have snakes.
I mean maybe they have some bugs,
but you rarely see legs.
Maybe these spiders and shit.
The problem with Australia,
excuse me,
the problem with Hawaii is it a lot of
the stuff that they have over there came
from somewhere else,
tremendous amount of things like birds
and they were stowaways on boats and
shit.
Spam,
spam pigs,
pigs in general,
like a little wild pigs and deer,
all these weird dear access deer from
Asia.
They just recently had to save the giant
parrot,
the Kakapo in a near Australia because
they were like 100 left because the Ra,
because they had no defenses.
They can't fly and the rats are eating
of all.
So they found,
they found all of them,
moved them to a different island,
killed the rats and brought her back and
now they're being saved.
Oh Wow.
They're really cool.
Well,
they've had a bunch of crazy experiments
in Australia with toads,
toads,
and then with bringing in cats and they
have feral cats and they kill all the
ground nesting birds and foxes to kill
the cats and cats like nasty.
Like they.
All they do is kill birds and like
rodents in small animals and we think
because they're cute and you've played
with their belly,
but they are killing machines.
Well,
they're cute.
If you raise them,
you have them at home and you
domesticate them and give them nothing
about cat food and pet them all the time
and they purr and they don't have any
desire to go out there and.
And eat and rape.
Yeah.
All cat sex is rape.
Well,
this way you look at it.
Will they have barb Dicks,
right?
Yeah.
They steal her up and then if you.
If the male cat sees a female with the
litter,
he kills the litter so she'll get a
population.
Again.
That's super common in the animal world,
unfortunately.
Yeah,
and the bear world,
it's even worse.
They eat them too.
They really.
Bears are almost 100 percent cannibals.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
The the male bears eat all the cubs.
It's like the best way.
It's.
It's so counterintuitive,
but the best way to ensure a healthy
population of bears is to kill a male's.
Wow.
Yeah.
You have to kill the old bores.
You go the like,
that's one of the reasons why they
actually encourage,
especially with black bears,
black bear hunting is encouraged,
is also really important because one of
the main things that they eat is Fonz,
like if you want to have healthy moose
populations in deer populations,
but yeah,
I was there in Alberta when a friend of
mine actually saw a bear kill a cub and
chase the mother way killed the cub and
then the mother came back and finished
the cub off.
She hated herself.
It's a dark world in the woods.
You think North Korea is rough being a
fucking bear?
Well,
my,
my I,
I might,
I.
my first job was writing for an aquarium
magazines.
I've been obsessed with animals since I
was a kid.
Aquariums.
That was my thing back in the day.
Oh Man.
I always wanted to have a massive
saltwater fish tank.
The best thing ever.
And I had all these secrets and shit.
Oh No,
no.
I had the kind of fish I had wrote my
friend called God's mistakes because
they all look like monsters.
So that's the kind of shit.
What did you have like a,
there's something called a big guy.
Uh,
there's something called a cal fish,
which can't,
it's encased in armor and can't move,
um,
and a soap fish which releases a cloud
of poisoned when it's upset.
And an Angler fish,
which also doesn't move at a slipper.
I may pull up these things there.
They all look like aliens.
So it was really kind of fun.
Yeah.
It's just electric catfish that you had
an electric shock.
You,
you in your balls.
Well,
I touched on electric eel.
We were on food fish.
Yes I do.
If you touch an electric eel,
you're going to get fucked up.
Those things are no joke.
No,
they're not that bad.
It can kill you.
How long?
How big was it?
That was big enough for me to grab.
I mean,
we,
we did it on fear factor was one of the
stones.
But you had to do it in one hand.
You can't do with both hands.
We also go through your heart,
remember?
Yes.
I remember this fear factor.
If something like,
Holy Shit,
where'd they get these electric eels for
them?
And the thing is they had to do with one
hand or else it makes a circuit if you
use them both hands.
Maybe.
I don't remember the slipper lobster,
but what I do remember is it sucked.
Like I definitely grabbed it and was
like,
yeah,
yeah.
It's no joke.
It's amazing that a small animal can
give you such a charge like that.
And it does it with its body.
The whole,
the anus is right by the mountain.
So the whole thing is electricity.
Yeah.
Isn't that cool?
That's why it's electric mouth was right
by the asshole.
It's all fucking confused you to notice
that it's crazy.
Look.
And what is that called?
A slipper.
Lobster slipper.
Have lobster tail.
It's often this face of that thing.
That's insane.
So instead of clause,
they have faced flaps.
The two hinges.
Whites.
Yeah.
If you look at the top,
do you see that one hinge and another?
Yeah,
that's one of the hinges goes up and
down the other goes left and right.
And all my guts.
So it's like the Predator.
Yeah,
it's really cool.
Do they have one with his mouth open?
Uh,
the mass underneath maybe meaning we're
where it's exposed,
where it's like grabbing something.
You'd have to be.
No,
so you won't see it because it wouldn't,
I would feed it,
it would grab it and put it near with
the belly.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And pull up a p,
R I s t e g e n y s I didn't know until
like two years ago what cuddle fish and
octopus could do.
My friend remy,
he used to have this show called Apex
Predator where he would study these
predators and try to figure out like
what strategies do you use for catching
their prey?
And one of the things that he studied
was a octopus and he came on Octopi and
he was like,
dude,
they're from another planet.
Their smartest cats.
The other very smart,
very smart,
super smart.
And they can not just change the way
they look,
but change their texture.
Right.
And they fit in perfectly with our
environment.
Yes.
He showed us some videos and I'm like,
how am I 48 years old and not knowing
about this.
They were absolutely.
And the ones at the bottom to see even
crazier.
Then you have the zebra octopus,
which is a mimic and the question you
have a philosophy person is,
is it consciously trying to look like
something else or data devolve.
Coincidentally it looked like because
they,
they look like flounders and then squids
and then lion fish and mantis shrimp and
like some of these forms wouldn't be
advantageous.
Like why would you want to look like a
flounder?
But it just changes from shape to shape
just very quickly.
Well not only that,
like how does it know what the
environment looks like to a point where
it could change it,
how does it know what it looks like?
It doesn't have a mirror.
And that's the other thing.
They put them on top of a checkerboard
deceased.
They can emit,
imitate it and they like,
they didn't know what to do.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well they can,
they can imitate all sorts of different
surfaces.
Coral and all sorts of different crazy
things.
And it's.
And what they'll do is they'll release
their cloud of ink and then what move.
But they'll just change shape.
So it looks like they vanished like a
super villain.
Yeah.
Well they think that that's like the.
There was one speculation that that
blast of ink that they shoot out is
almost like the like correction fluid,
like white out.
Like those are,
that's not what I meant.
Like oh wow.
That they do it to each other,
like to like to stop conversations and
that part of what they're doing when
they're changing their body is like a
visual form of communication that will.
They definitely do like the,
like chameleons.
Also.
Communities don't always change color
for evolution.
They'll do it for protection.
They'll become red show anger and its
mood.
Like a lot of fish.
I've had changed color based on mood to
communicate.
It's fascinating.
Mood fish like mood rings,
better mood rings.
Well it's good because some fish when
they are the water's dirty,
they'll be a different color.
So you'll know it's time for water
change.
The catfish did that.
Oh,
when they look sick,
you know,
they just get darker.
Oh just not good.
It's just dusky or it's like,
all right,
I need to make him lemonade colored
again.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
I thought that when they put an octopus
on checkerboard that did
mimic the checkerboard,
it couldn't figure it couldn't get it
right.
Can you find that?
That was confusing to me.
They did.
There was something similar to that.
Maybe some sort of a striped pattern
that it mimicked the strife steak I
think they can do,
but the checker boards the problem,
if I remember correctly.
So what are the best one is the
flamboyant cuttlefish.
They just discovered it's two inches
long walks,
but it's colored like a,
like a.
it's like an acid trip and they're just
fascinating.
Look,
flamboyant.
That's the official name.
Flamboyant cuttlefish.
Isn't it true that they've only,
they've only researched like 10 percent
of the ocean floor.
Oh yeah.
It's insane.
That's,
I mean that's my friend came up with the
name God's mistakes because God made
some fish.
He's like,
well no one's gonna.
See that.
They're just throwing the in the ocean
because they all look like monsters.
And I.
my theory is because there's no light
down there that things like visuals
which are based on mathematics don't
apply,
so it's okay that they're hideous
because no one's going to be seeing
them.
What about bioluminescent fish and
phosphorescent ones?
Yeah.
There's weird ones that they create
their own light bulbs.
They all have.
They almost all have them.
There's one which uses red light because
others can't see red and they use them
like search lights.
Oh yeah.
There's so much crazy shit.
The bottom of the sea.
It's so fascinating.
I mean,
if we found what's really fascinating to
me is if we found any of this stuff in
space,
we'd be freaking out.
This is why I never could like star trek
because it drove me crazy as an autistic
young boy are you autistic,
but for this purpose I am that I would
know all these zoological animals that
look like insane things.
Walking back fish,
which you can't swim,
and then I turned on Star Trek.
It's another planet and it's a guy with
fucking blue skin and like
I can get blue skin.
Show me something that's not based on
the human form.
You fucking ass each all the job is.
Here's the octopus cuttlefish,
cuttlefish octopus,
Java.
The Hudson was what blew my mind as a
kid because they look like aliens.
Well,
my favorite one was that stupid lizard
guy that Captain Kirk had a fight with.
Oh God,
I remember that one.
I never watched star trek for this
reason.
I'm not even joking.
It's so bad.
Okay,
so here's the cuttlefish.
He's on the ground and there's a like a
sandy bottom,
and he kind of looks like the sandy
bottom and then they put this at the
beginning.
It took it off so could switch back.
The Best I did was that little block.
Wow.
That's pretty impressive.
If we fucking close,
you did its best,
but how did it know?
The eyes are on the side,
so they're looking at an old directions
at once,
like a rabbit or.
But as a no,
to make a square.
Right?
What the fuck?
Look what it's doing it right there.
It's kind of Holy Shit.
That's creepy.
Wow.
Jesus Christ.
Look a flamboyant cuttlefish.
You got to see this shit.
It's toxic as hell to these animals.
I mean,
what caused them to evolve like this and
they've been around forever.
Forever and they also have very short
lifespans.
Yeah.
So it's not even working.
What keeps you alive?
How long week
look like,
God,
this is insane.
Holy Shit.
I'm tripping.
And those always are it.
It's not the.
It's not the water.
It's making it look like there's a wave
of skin.
Wow.
Look at us eyes too,
right?
Because they're the first ones.
They found that walk.
It looks like a tiny water.
Hippo is that lady.
She's cute and she just wants to know.
She's cute.
Look at that thing.
My God.
Amazing.
That is amazing.
And I think that's hypnotic.
It's meant to be hypnotic.
Lucky break up.
Oh,
look at that.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
You look at it and it shoots this
fucking alien thing like the Ridley
Scott Alien.
Find them out the second time now and
jabs at fish fuckin a man.
Like if we found that on Jupiter or rice
or something like we'll be freaking out.
It's two inches.
You're like,
what the fuck is this shit?
Yeah.
I mean,
if this was anywhere,
if they found this,
you know,
pick a pick a planet in our solar
system,
we would be so obsessed with it.
But the fact that it's in the ocean,
like,
yeah,
it's right over there.
Who gives a fuck?
I just found it pretty recently to
really.
Yeah.
I think in the nineties there was a
website that was dedicated to a bunch of
animals that were uncovered during one
of the tsunamis.
I think it was the big tsunami that hit.
Was it Vietnam or Thailand?
Oh,
was it
somewhere?
Yeah,
but there was a,
I think now that I'm saying is I feel
like it was debunked.
Like someone said,
no,
that's not where they came from,
but it was a series of super bizarre
animals that were found super bizarre
fish they found at the bottom of the
ocean that literally looked like they
came from another world.
Look up.
There's something called a uh,
um,
mouse trap fish where it's now,
it's like a mouse trap.
It's hinged and it,
it,
it works like a mouse trap.
Well,
how about the anglerfish?
He's got a fishing pole hanging off his
fucking head.
Well,
I had.
There's a bunch of different kinds of
angler fishes and the best,
there's one called the clown angler
fish,
which has warts all over it and they're
very brightly colored.
And this they to do Jamie.
This one,
I'm sorry.
We're almost asking them too many things
to google.
Just one thing.
This is the one they'll blow your
fucking mind.
The football fish.
And what's amazing about them is the
females are like a yard,
but the males are two inches long and
the males attached the females and lose
their sense of identity becomes sperm
glands.
Oh look,
regular dudes.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
So they,
they couldn't figure out where the males
were for a long time.
The female said just these growths on
them.
And they were male.
They were the males Angler anglerfish.
Well crazy.
The football fish.
And I typed it in.
So,
but,
but he's tricking backwards with that
photograph,
but there's one with the dangle it
dangles if that's as a female.
So she dangles it in.
Yeah.
That's looked at that they dangled over
there.
And then the other,
Hey,
what's going on over here?
And inhale.
Some
definitely you just missed the teeth on
that fucking thing.
And some of them have outside the mouth.
Those are the OBC anglers.
Go back to Jamie,
the name that's the family Holo fry,
California Day.
That's the family,
the family of Angler fish.
And there's a bunch of families to them.
Wow.
Look at that thing.
God,
there's so many of them.
How many Angler fish are there?
Look at the one that tank show that one,
that one,
that one.
They have one in display.
Look at that.
Hold our creep.
Yeah.
I mean that doesn't even look like a
real thing.
Right?
Wow.
It's an amazing look at that one.
That one's bio luminescence?
Yeah.
You could see where the spots are.
Ah,
that's beautiful.
Yeah.
And they can't keep them in a cramped.
What is that called?
It's also anti football fish.
Go back,
go back to.
So what do you get add over there?
Uh,
Atlantic.
Look at that thing.
Oh yeah.
The colors in that thing.
And it looks like it's bolted together.
Oh yeah.
It looks like patchwork.
Like some sort of an animated movie
there.
There's the deep sea is my favorite kind
of stuff with all this crazy shit.
But what's the most underappreciated and
overlooked?
Go to that one.
That's up right above that,
Jamie.
The one.
Yeah,
right there.
What does that one?
Yeah,
they're all.
Do you want to see something real thing,
man,
that's,
that does not look real.
Yeah.
God,
these things are amazing.
Look up,
um,
red lipped walking batfish fish because
there's one that's a relative of this.
There wears lipstick.
Walking,
walking back fish.
Wow.
Why in the fuck is that thing?
They can't swim.
So they.
Yeah,
they have a nose and out of the nose is
where the angle comes from.
That's my favorite fish.
Look at that shit.
Oh my God.
Look at the lips.
Yeah.
Wow.
Isn't that amazing?
Yeah.
They're like,
they're very hard to keep in captivity
to species because they always have
parasites.
Oh,
is that why?
Yeah.
Why can't they keep great whites in
captivity?
Because a great whites are extremely
sensitive to electric impulses in the
water,
so they keep banging their heads against
the wall,
plus their pelagic,
which means they live in the ocean where
there's nothing around them,
so they're not used to any barriers,
so this really fucks them up.
They need to be able to go full speed
for miles at a time.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
that's interesting.
They got a whale sharks in captivity
that Georgia,
and they've got three in Georgia and
Atlanta.
How big is the tank?
It's Jack gets the biggest tank in the
world,
or second biggest.
Yeah,
the glass was like two feet thick,
so the crazy.
So it seems stupid to keep them
go,
go see them in the ocean,
man,
Philippines for them.
The Great.
Then watch them on video just seems
fucked up to me.
To keep those things in captivity just
doesn't make any sense.
They're there.
Yeah,
I guess.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Great.
If you could talk to them,
you know,
probably be like prisoners,
like super bummed out.
It's just like North Korea,
but for fish.
Well,
I used to have a joke about that,
about like someone like saying like,
hey man,
you know,
things that bad.
I went to the zoo,
I saw these chimps playing with a rope
and they look,
they're having a good time.
I go,
yeah,
go to prison.
You Watch dudes playing basketball.
Doesn't mean it's awesome.
Right,
right.
Especially with the higher end in prison
that are intelligent.
Yeah.
It's like if people have pets were
birds.
I don't.
I'm a big pet person,
but the bird wants to be flying around.
Yeah.
Like when they clip their wings.
Now you don't need these.
Yeah.
I needed to keep you around.
The only thing that makes you special
and I want to say hello.
Let me clip your wings.
Yeah,
it is.
I don't know,
we're weird.
We're weird with our dominance over
other animals,
but I mean I guess every animal that has
control over their animals is weird.
Like if you've seen that thing about
dolphins,
they take puffer fish and they get high
with them,
they pass them around.
What?
I killer whales,
they kill babies for fun.
Oh yeah.
They have a good time.
They're sick.
Well yeah.
It will.
Dolphins do the exact same thing that
you were talking about.
The cats do where they kill off the,
the young to make the female breed
because a female dolphin won't go into
breeding.
I think it's like six or seven years
while she was raising the kid.
Okay.
Yeah.
So one of the things that females do to
mitigate this is they fuck as many males
as they can because they obviously they
don't have Maury Povich and DNA tests
and the ocean.
So they fuck is.
They're like extremely promiscuous.
And the idea behind it,
if they fuck enough of these males,
the guy will have no idea whose baby is
so think it's his baby fuck to you.
That might be my kid.
All right.
I'm not going to eat them.
My knowledge if the C is just limited to
fish.
So let's get some novelists.
I'm looking,
I've kind of like c student,
but you're a Dork,
like you really love it.
I'm a Dork.
Uh,
all different kinds of species.
I can rattle off things all day,
like every.
What do you think about the Tasmanian
Tiger?
Do you think that things alive that day?
They're thinking of trying to clone it
back because they have ones in
Formaldehyde,
do they?
Yeah.
So it died out in the twenties,
I believe.
Uh,
I think it's somewhere around there and
because we have video of it,
yes.
One in captivity and they are thinking
of trying to clone it and bring it back.
I didn't know that.
There it is right there.
What a great is fabulous.
It's the only animal that can open.
It's not like 120 degrees or something.
Well,
they think that they might have a few of
them still in the wild because Australia
is essentially the size of the
contiguous United States,
but with the same amount of people in
Los Angeles and they think that it might
be possible because there's been several
sightings at these things,
but then you gotta think there's several
sightings and bigfoot.
I love cryptozoology.
It's.
It's just absolutely fascinating because
even the coloration looks like they'll
copy which is the giraffes closest
relative and they thought that was fake
and then they found one another in zoos.
You could see it's a crazy looking at
them.
Yeah,
but do you think that that thing is.
I mean there's enough sightings where
they're starting to actively consider.
There was a a movie with what the Fuck
Willem defoe several years ago where
someone had hired him to go and shoot a
Tasmanian Tiger that they knew were one
was and that somebody wanted it to stuff
at or something like that.
There was this species of insect on St
Helena Island,
I think it was where they thought it was
extinct or they found a bush.
There had 13 of them and now they bred
them and there's like thousands,
so if they found one it would be great
because they'd be able to breed them to
huge numbers pretty quickly.
Also,
it's like one of the last predators
other than like saltwater crocodiles,
right?
In Australia.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The dingoes no joke there.
They've been taken out a lot of stuff.
They have that whole dingo fence for
that reason.
Yeah.
Australia is a really weird place,
man.
Some of mine were just over there.
They were hunting water buffaloes.
Oh,
it was Asian water buffaloes.
Huge,
huge.
And also an invasive species.
So these things come over and they just
destroy the water like anything else.
That truck 2000 plus millions and they
just shit everywhere and ruin all the
water sources.
So all these birds,
all these different animals that need
that water all getting fucked up and
dying.
Did you ever see one when it took out
the lion?
I did see something like that recently.
Yeah.
Where there's like a Cape Buffalo.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's just the macy says kill.
It just swings at end of the line,
goes flying like 20 feet.
Have you ever seen the documentary
relentless enemies?
No.
It's fascinating.
It's so good because it's about these
lines that adapted to only eat water
buffalo.
What happened was they had a change in
the current of the river,
changed the course of a river and an
isolated this one island of lions and
they only had two things to eat and one
of the things was Cape Buffalo,
which are fucking enormous,
so these lions became freakish mutan
lions,
enormous lions,
like the average female is the size of
an average male,
La and everywhere else in Africa,
but google relentless enemies,
giant killer lions because the females
don't even look real.
They look like hulk lions.
They're fucking Jack.
This is another reason I'm very
skeptical about this climate change
stuff because nature is far more
adaptable than we give it credit for.
Oh,
you mean climate change in that?
Like the doom and gloom.
Like if the temperature is that one
degree that the corals can't handle it.
I don't buy it will move to Canada,
Canada.
I love it.
I love Canada.
I love Toronto,
see if you get these.
These are the ones going after it,
but see if you can get an image of some
of the lions from relentless enemies
because they're just get.
Just Google it.
Go and look.
Don't just keep popping these up on the
screen because there's some of them.
If you go and look and find it,
you can find ones that are just jacked.
That's relentless enemies.
Yeah,
but see if you can find like a good
image of the lives
right next to it.
That one?
Yeah,
that one.
No,
it's not.
They're good.
There's some really good ones.
There's some really good ones where they
look freakish.
There's a good look at the size of that
fucker like that is so much bigger than
the average female lion.
That's crazy.
It's because they're.
All they're eating is east cape
buffaloes.
He's fucking enormous buffalo's so
they've grown to like 600 pounds for the
average female lion there are much
bigger.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
They're huge.
They're.
They look so huge that even look real
and they still even this big.
They have to gang up on him.
Of course,
jump on their back and one of them jumps
on the leg and I mean it's just.
But the documentary is amazing and
interestingly enough,
there's several prides of lion on this
one island and then not all that big.
It's just one pride is that big.
The other prides are like fairly normal
sized,
but one pride has.
It's just freakishly large species of
lion.
You know,
I ran through a lot of scenarios,
but what we're going to be talking
today,
and this was not one of them,
I didn't went
through any scenarios.
I mean I knew we were going to talk.
We're sure about North Korea,
but I didn't know.
We're going to talk about giant lines or
psychedelic cuddle fish.
What's it called again?
Flamboyant.
Flamboyant cuttlefish.
What a perfect name.
Yeah.
Why do they always use these fucking
Latin names?
Because that way,
and this happens with when you into
aquariums,
if I'm sending you something from
England to America or England to
Cambodia,
you know,
we're speaking the exact same species
because what you might call a gray
parrot is not the same as what I would
call a great parent.
That makes sense.
That's interesting that he chose a dead
language.
Well,
that way it's universal.
Right?
That makes sense.
Why don't just use English since we kick
ass?
Because
America
speak American and world American.
I'm sorry,
those America.
We've got a by England in this.
Just take over that.
That name of the language.
Keep calling it English like enough
already.
You guys wouldn't be it,
right?
You guys speak wrong and he spelled
tires wrong too.
I really think that they've evolved that
accent to come off as smarter than they
really are.
I think Americans are smarter than
British people and it's a big lie.
That's rude.
You're racist against who?
The British?
Yes are.
They're all ugly.
So.
Oh,
how dare you have not seen a sporty
spice?
She isn't she the hot one was the hot
one.
Boy,
it's pretty hot.
She's American and I decided the hot
ones are American,
but the thing is,
it's when you hear British people talk,
you think they're smart and you talk to
them like you're not that fucking smart.
You just stood accent Guy Ritchie's
really fucking smart.
Well,
he's one data point.
Madonna,
you're trolling.
I see what you're doing.
Wait,
wait.
You wait.
You read a lot of people from America
and English.
Do you think English people generally
smarter than Americans?
I think that people vary widely.
Okay,
but you could still do a lot of really
dumb American people.
Of course,
a lot of really dumb American beat,
but I think there's a lot of really dumb
British people.
I'm sure.
Yeah,
I never met him.
Everyone I met as a genius from England.
Everyone,
all of them.
Oh fuck that guy.
Ritchie and sporty spice.
Sporty guy.
Ritchie.
Well,
you haven't.
Madonna,
and she's a genius listener of Madonna's
English now.
Gave them.
We gave her away.
I mean the idea that you can with a
straight face just put makeup,
a British accent.
You got to realize the kind of Dick that
Guy Ritchie was slinging.
He fucked her up so bad that she doesn't
work anymore and she speaks English.
She barely even saying that is.
That is stigmatized if I've ever seen
it.
He's just laying that fucking lock stock
and two smoking barrels.
Are they.
They're divorced though,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
But she's still fucked up from it.
She was really fucked up.
He's recovered greatly,
but she's really like,
really?
She's a mess.
She's got like those tweety birds for
cartoons
was
the universal thing for somebody fucked
up.
Birds would circled it.
How did we know what they meant?
Like someone got clocked over the head
with a frying pan and we'd see those
birds.
Tweet,
tweet,
and where are you going to?
Yeah.
That got fucked up and I think she's got
a mix of those birds and cuckoo clocks.
Yeah.
Well it's got to be hard,
man.
When you're like a sex symbol for women
is like,
there's this weird phase that women go
through,
which is very disturbing.
Everyone except Christie Brinkley who
had still.
Fuck,
sorry.
Sorry.
No disrespect,
but she's like in her sixties,
she's still hot,
but every other woman who's like really
hot,
when she was in her twenties,
they get to this certain age and either
they let it go like Meryl Streep and
just accept an age gracefully or they
start shooting a bunch of shit in my
face and they get real weird looking.
Right?
Or they just become like a monster and
so they go from being extremely
desirable to repulsive the uncanny
valley,
the Uncanny Valley of deals with
software,
but it deals with like when robots look
too close to human beings,
it's repulsive,
right?
Artificial intelligence,
what they use artificial.
I'm a virtual reality.
Right?
But the point is someone has to look
like a person,
but not too much like a person who has
this creepy.
So they become like,
you look human almost.
Right.
So then it becomes very repellent.
Yeah,
that's what's.
That's what's tweaky about.
We went to Nvidia a few years back when
I was doing this Scifi show and this
was,
I want to say 2012 or 13 where they were
just getting good at this virtual
reality software and the reproduction of
the human body,
but they couldn't get eyelashes
downright.
Oh,
like blinking.
It was weird like that.
So you'd watched this guy,
Tom,
like there was something weird about the
blinking,
trying to give you a message and code.
Fucking bizarre.
Like wasn't there some Vietnam hostage?
American POW.
It's blinking.
Sos.
Oh yeah.
What was that?
I think that's what I think it was that
POW two,
three,
one,
two,
three.
Yeah.
They'd probably killed him.
Yeah,
they,
I mean the Americans that the Koreans
had hostage did similar shit and they
got tortured be unbelief.
While that was something I was reading
about China,
about how many CIA operatives in China
had been killed over the last two years?
Like 18.
Is that.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
18 different informants had been killed
or jailed over the last couple of years
and they were complaining we can.
We can't fucking spy on them anymore.
It's like,
hey,
like they don't want you spying like to
get it,
but with the way we look at it,
like we're allowed a spy.
Like you can't be killing people.
That is.
Yeah.
So they're interviewing him here.
Can you hear it?
Oh my,
a I can't.
I believe in.
I'm a member of that group.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Vietnam.
There's something entirely terrifying
about watching someone who is a prisoner
of war.
Oh yeah.
So when John Mccain has these racist
quotes,
sometimes it's like,
you know what?
You get it pass.
You can't even,
you,
you're fine.
You can't lift your hands over your
head.
You're,
you do whatever you say.
Whatever you want.
You've earned it.
Yeah.
He.
How does he get dressed?
Like is he can only do this.
Yeah.
Well that's because they broke his arm
data.
Yeah,
like a shoulders.
I think they pulled them and kind of had
him hanging by his wrist.
I believe if it's just an still have and
you know,
he can't tie his tie and all this stuff.
It's like,
you know,
you can say you can use slurs.
That's fine.
You're saying it's okay.
I think for him,
you know,
so it's just like,
yeah,
get them some stem cells.
Shit,
my mom listen to this shit.
My Mom,
God bless her heart,
started taking stem cells by which it
was plant stems in a pill form.
Oh Jesus.
And I'm just like,
I just,
I you.
What do you say to that?
What did she think it was going to do to
her?
I mean,
stem cells are good for your energy and
also what you said,
I don't even fucking know I at that
point,
you're just like,
okay mom.
Well they are,
they are a loophole.
Go,
you're going to live forever.
Wonder like if John Mccain's ever tried
to do anything about his shoulders or if
it's just like,
fuck it.
I'm sure he did.
I mean I wonder this is decades at this
point.
He's a fascinating character.
Yeah.
He's a grumpy old dude and sometimes it
makes a whole lot of sense and a lot of
people will like totally down for him
being president and all of a sudden he
goes,
Sarah Pailin running with them and
you're like,
what are you doing man?
I'm like,
what the fuck is going on?
That sort of unveiled the machinery
behind the Republicans and like what?
What do you think America is like?
You think America is like some sort of
weird reality show.
Some honey booboo type shit or this lady
is should be one heartbeat away from
being the fucking president.
When she came out,
she had,
when she was nominated,
she had the highest approval rating of
any governor in America and her first
capitalist speeches.
Everyone's like,
oh yeah,
this lady is a ball buster.
And then interview hit and you're like,
Holy Shit.
She doesn't read.
She's.
She's like had learning disabled.
Yeah.
Well I don't know if she's learned to
say,
but I just don't think she's interested
in learning.
I read her book and it was really
interesting.
Or You read her book.
There's only so many hours in a day.
How many days in a week,
so many years in your life that can read
North Korean propaganda could read this
and there's this one point in the book
where I'm like,
her ghost writer should be fired because
she,
her daughter,
willow,
whatever goes to her,
mommy,
why don't you ever cry?
And I'm like,
this is a murder mystery.
That's how you know she's a sociopath
and it's in the book.
I'm like,
Holy Shit,
that's terrifying.
Mommy's too dumb to cry.
I don't think it's just,
Mommy's just don't understand sadness.
It's just skin over wires and circuitry.
Oh Man.
See,
I didn't see that.
I just saw her as being adored.
Well,
like it came out.
I think there's,
just like with George W Bush,
you remember the first 2000,
he won those debates against Gore,
or at least held his own and then there
was just declined to the point where
he's not even speak English.
Well,
do you remember when George Bush was
running for Governor of Texas?
Now?
I don't.
I mean,
I,
I wouldn't have noticed that I'm from
New York.
Well,
um,
the reason why I remember is because
they show the stark contrast between his
ability to communicate while he was
running for governor versus his ability
to communicate once it became president.
I felt like he was almost like a guy who
had all his responsibility taken away
from him and he just like atrophied.
Like Dick Cheney was kinda running the
show and he was just sitting back
fucking up lines and making mistakes
with things.
But if you watch the speeches that he
gave,
a kid will play this
a perspective.
I think that the mission in education
and literature,
math,
science and social science,
it's still different to enrich beyond
that,
more power to them.
But yeah.
Wow,
that's a different person.
We all know it gets better.
Four subject matters and see if we can
do it right.
We ought to determine the cost per pupil
necessary to achieve excellence in the
classroom.
And we all to funded the funding
priority of the state of Texas,
the school children of our state.
And it has not been under the past four
years.
The state share of education has
decreased to 44 percent.
That is why we have property taxes on
the rise and nearly every single school
district in
stable
defined the mission determine the cost
per pupil necessarily.
You see reading from the teleprompter
elected government.
No,
clearly not
say that the number one funding priority
of our state will be the schoolchildren
of Texas.
Holy Shit.
Amazing and compare George Bush 10 years
ago to George Bush today,
now so that in the video it says this,
listen to them now.
Awesome
for dealing with nuclear proliferation,
about 35 percent since I've been the
president.
Now.
Secondly,
we set up what's called the.
Well first of all,
I agree with it.
My opponent that the biggest threat
facing this country is there a weapons
of mass destruction in the hands of a
terrorist network.
Yeah,
he was clear and concise,
but he was also a younger man.
You have to realize like,
this is an older man.
He's tired and the grind of being the
president for four years was wearing on
him so hard when he was running against
Kerry there.
I mean,
he was just a beaten man and I just
think that job is just unbelievably
draining,
like some sort of a psychic vampire just
locks onto you and saps you of all your
fucking Mitochondria.
Well,
he doesn't have an excuse because his
dad was president,
so he would have known what it's like
maybe his dad was only president for
four years now only.
I mean,
come on.
That's not going to be a short four
years.
Yeah,
and his dad was the head of the CIA for
that.
So his dad was maybe more deeply
entrenched in the ideas of politics than
he was.
And I met his uncle.
I went to Gail with a friend of mine who
was doing a masters t and that guy I was
ready to go out,
come out swinging.
I thought it was going to be a troll.
That guy charmed the fucking pants off
me and I'm like,
Holy Shit.
I can see why these people are in power
one on one.
They are so charming,
will win.
Jeb was running for president,
so I almost felt like he was thrown in
the towel.
I felt like he was like,
I'm just going to go through the motions
and fuck some of this up.
Just like
Rick Perry when Rick Perry was like.
And then there's something I forgot.
Yeah,
I remember that.
What about,
did you say Jeb Bush is tweet when he,
when he,
when he quit,
he said,
sorry mom.
That was his tweet.
Jabba tweeted this out.
Yes.
Wow.
His mom's probably secretly happy.
Well,
she,
she didn't want him to run Barbara.
She said that publicly before he
announced.
Yeah,
she's like,
enough tooth and two is enough.
Well,
it's a monarchy.
Yeah.
What's also crazy to me,
why would he want to do it at that?
Right?
Who the hell knows why does anybody want
to do it?
But he seemed to be like the least
qualified of album.
Will trump's the least qualified in the
bushes?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
And as far as his ability to
communicate,
he was like the worst of it.
No.
So Jeb,
in 1996,
I think it was,
he ran for reelection against this guy.
I forgot his name.
Baylor bend something.
And they were tied and then they had a
debate and Jeb crushed him so bad that
he ended up winning by double digits.
The Guy who'd be generating in the
primaries.
It was bill mcbride,
I think is his name.
This was for Florida?
Yeah,
when he was reelected.
Governor of Florida.
So he was a beast again,
back in the day.
And then you have these debates and he's
standing there,
you know?
I mean it was,
it was hilarious too.
I think he just didn't want to do it.
The thing was like,
I don't think fast.
I don't think any of them have ever
known what to do with a trump figure,
especially who's leading them.
And when the guy's been trump's on stage
saying,
this guy's a real sick guy.
He said he was going to pull down his
pants and moon everyone.
And Jeff's like,
what do you say to that?
Is that what trump says?
Yes.
And
it will be really fascinating if Alec
Baldwin ran against trump.
You think he's gonna run?
No,
I don't.
But it would be fascinating because
there's a guy who not only did trump on
Syrah live,
but is more than capable of holding his
own and that kind of a fist to cuff sort
of a debate like if he,
if it insults being thrown back and
forth,
and that kind of.
I told us a great [inaudible] you
remember when Alec Baldwin lost the Shit
and the reporter and called him a fag
and all this other stuff.
Remember this.
So Alec was that.
But it wasn't that guy a popper off to
fine.
The point is he's taking pictures of his
family.
He's got emotionally worked up,
he's got thin skin.
And that's not in those,
in those debates.
Trump knows how to swing.
Right?
But Alec Baldwin's never been in debate.
The point is,
if Alec Baldwin loses his shit,
he's trying to present himself as the
same of alternative to this lunatic.
So if they're both saying they're both
fucking lunatics,
was baldwins advantage?
Better looking.
I'm not nearly as power hungry,
not a billionaire oligarch type.
Anyone thought trump was power hungry?
That wasn't the knock against him.
But they definitely thought it was money
hungry.
Well yeah,
but like Ted Cruz came up as much more
power hungry.
I think that trump did well.
The Ted Cruz was kind of sunk by those
weird commercial out clips.
We the outtakes where you got to see
them Redo it.
Oh yeah.
I remember when he said it was my.
It was my mother play prays for me for
an hour everyday and she was like,
his daughter wouldn't kiss him.
Yeah.
His daughter wouldn't kiss ever.
There was awkward
hugs and they had a redo takes and it's
like,
whoa.
My favorite thing during the primaries
was ted Cruz's regardless,
like the best debater in Washington.
Right?
Izzy?
Yeah.
They all respect him that he was like,
it has this long debate history from
what was it?
Harvard or Yale or where he went to.
And this guy could practice for 100
years with 100 different fake opponents.
And in that time,
no one would ever think of throwing at
him.
Your Dad Shot Jfk.
What was that about?
How about the Zodiac killer shit.
He kept calling the Zodiac cat.
That's the green frog approach.
That's the green frog effect.
Yes.
It's wonderful trolls.
I started calling Hillary America's
mother-in-law and that caught on a bit
and that's how you have to take down
these people is not through their ideas,
but just kind of take their strengths
and turn them into weaknesses.
That's hilarious.
I remember there was a real clear moment
during the campaign were Ted Cruz had
not yet stepped away,
not,
not yet resigned,
but there was.
He was at a speech and somehow or
another some trump supporter was in the
front row wearing sunglasses,
telling them to quit and calling them
lying Ted and saying,
you've already lost.
When are you going to quit?
And he was trying to engage.
This guy was outside and I was like,
oh,
this guy's fucked up.
He doesn't know how to deal with like a
real person.
What about when he had fear?
Rena as his running mate and she follows
up the stage at their announcement.
It was like this curb your enthusiasm
moment.
It was amazing.
How is this ever going to turn it
around?
Like what?
What do you anticipate happening?
My whole 2020,
my hope is that the gears of government
are going to be increasingly shut down,
that political communication becomes
impossible and we start breaking this
stuff apart.
That's my goal.
But don't you?
Don't you think it will take like
forever to come up with some new sort of
structure to run this?
I don't think we need to angled con.
I don't think we need a structure.
I think a lot of the structures in place
that most of the interaction you have
between humans is already there with
structure.
We didn't have any structure here for me
to get here,
right?
So I don't think we're gonna need much
replacing.
Right?
But,
but there's no way that the people that
are in the positions of power right now,
whether there'll be senators,
republican congressmen,
Republicans,
Democrats,
whoever the fuck it is,
no way.
They're just going to accept the fact
that the structure doesn't exist in.
Correct.
So the way to do that as technology.
And here's,
here's an example I always use like
let's suppose it's 1980,
right?
And me and you are technologically
advanced.
Humans have walked on the moon,
you know,
we have mobile phones,
so on and so forth and you and I are
having an argument about censorship and
you're saying we need to censor some
things might come for child pornography.
I'm like,
we have to have free speech and Jamie
appears from 2017 and he goes,
you guys are wasting your time because
soon you will be able to copy any book
with one button and with one button you
can send it anywhere on earth at the
speed of light.
How much does it cost?
It's free and if you have to have a
magic words to other people can read
this books.
A censorship is technically impossible.
You would.
We would both look at him like he's
crazy,
but that's what's happened.
So technology is increasingly.
I'm binding the hands of government.
When we were kids,
the idea that apple with apple didn't
exist then maybe,
but the apple would tell the government,
we're making a lock on our phones that
even we can't open because we understand
that you are the problem.
That would have been unthinkable.
And now we have corporations openly
defying the state because they realized
that they are often the enemy.
And that's wonderful.
Uber,
look,
his whole model is we're gonna,
we're gonna ask for forgiveness,
not permission.
We're going to break the law until you
guys say it's illegal.
We're not going to have licensing.
It's great and we're going to become
entrenched in the city until you know,
then you can't get us out.
And then someone might lift,
comes along and says,
well,
they're doing it,
but they're not doing it.
Right,
right.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And then that's the spirit of
competition.
Yes.
It's a beautiful thing.
I just wonder how that applies to
government.
Well,
because if the government's hands are
tied with religions,
then people are going to negotiate
through piece
just like we do now.
Like I mean if you have a problem with
macy's,
you either return the sweater,
you take the loss,
but it's,
it's fine.
But how does that play out though in
like a real life scenario?
I think what's going to have to happen
is just like with books and books,
you know,
it can go anywhere or at the speed of
light.
Once you have people being able to move
very quickly from place to place,
they're going to start becoming
effectively the
property of whatever country they happen
to be in because right now we have
things divided by geography,
but if you have your have landline
technology when it comes to government
as a in a cell phone world or even a
beyond cell phone world,
if you had it where I'm the government
or whatever cell phone provider I have
that would carry with me if I'm in
Taiwan or Russia or the United States as
opposed to when I'm in the between these
two oceans,
it's US law when I'm in between these
two oceans is British law.
That's fascinating.
So do you think that in the future we'll
see like a dissolving of borders for the
ability to travel back that I think a
lot of people support that that's
already started happening.
Yeah,
it's.
I mean the idea.
Like right now,
I could go any country on earth,
including North Korea right now,
let's listen to case a hundred years
ago,
this trump thing that got him elected.
One of the things was build that wall,
build that wall,
this.
Do you think that this is like a retro
idea or an idea of like almost like a
longing for nostalgia,
like a pushing back against technology,
pushing back against progress.
Think it's the pushing forward for the
idea of self segregation and the idea
that you should surround yourself with
people that you choose as opposed to
people that you are forced to surround
yourself with and that people are pack
animals and I shouldn't have to.
The idea that me and my neighbors in my
building,
I get to sit down and make a consensus
is bullshit.
I want to sit down with my friends and
make a consensus.
Right?
But that's what you're talking about.
The whole entire United States though,
the building,
the wall between us and Mexico,
but the point seems to me that they're
just wanting to keep out the unfortunate
people.
Well,
they also want to keep themselves as a
cohesive whole,
right,
so they want to maintain this idea of
Americanness,
whereas they're being told that
Americanists means everyone on earth can
come here.
Well,
they're not saying that.
They're just saying.
I mean no one's really saying that
anybody can come here.
A lot of people,
I mean if you're going to what?
I've never heard any criteria for saying
we can't let this group in.
There's always some reason for letting
each and every group in and there's
never a reason to say no.
While the.
The rational filter would be,
we don't want anyone in here that has an
extensive violent criminal history,
right?
Or I mean it could be levels of
education,
levels of vacation,
of education.
Rather someone who wants to come to this
country.
This is a country of immigrants.
This is a country where people try to do
better,
right?
If you're coming here from somewhere
else and you want to come to America,
but you would,
you would be coming here because you
want to do better.
You want to elevate yourself or elevate
your family or give your children the
opportunity to be educated in a way that
you weren't sure.
That's kind of what this is founded on.
That way it was founded on it,
so it's become.
It's certainly wasn't founded on the
idea for a country of immigrants.
The founding fathers weren't like,
yeah,
immigrants.
My hero,
Alexander Hamilton was an immigrant.
I'm an immigrant,
but certainly.
I mean there's plenty of reasons to have
criteria for why people are let it just
kind of.
But how do you define immigrants?
Just because like if I'm in a war torn
country,
hell yeah,
I want to go to America because it's
going to be better for me and my family
a hundred percent.
That's understandable.
That doesn't mean that I'm bringing
something to the table to America.
Not always.
Right.
Well,
I mean you can't say that even about
someone who comes from a thriving.
Correct me
to come over from England,
as I said earlier and they're ugly,
ugly,
looser,
so maybe we should have a contest of six
or above us.
How do you feel?
Do you feel you're a six?
Uh,
I,
I think I'm above a sex the way you are,
but if you were in Holland,
the men are all giant,
handsome.
I think he might not be as sick as well.
Good thing I'm not in Holland.
Don't let any of those people over here.
Yeah,
we got to Sweden.
Mr. President,
please.
New comment if I would make them bigger
though.
Not going to be 20 feet tall,
but the.
Yeah,
right.
They'll grow Godzilla lions.
Exactly.
Under pressure.
Right.
But I mean,
but going back to the immigrant thing,
I mean,
this country,
essentially everyone who is here who's
not native American at one point in time
was an immigrant.
Sure.
But I mean there's different types of
differences.
The immigrants who try to assimilate and
there's the immigrants who don't
assimilate and just because we've done
some assimilate,
I don't see anybody walking around with
Buckskin on wearing feathers.
I mean there's no one assimilate it from
Europe.
What do you mean I've assimilated?
Well,
sort of,
but I mean the original people that came
here,
people that came here.
If you're going to assimilate,
you're going to assimilate with the
native Americans.
No one did that.
Sure.
They conquered them.
He can say that.
Yeah.
I mean it was more like genocide than
conquering,
but Jenna isn't genocide just when you
conquer really well?
Well,
yeah,
in a lot of it is unfortunately because
of disease.
Well,
it's also the fact.
I mean the idea that it genocide.
I mean these native Americans were tough
cookies.
These were not these like nature hippies
that they're made out to be.
I mean there's the reason that baseball
teams are native to native Americans
because they were mean.
They chopped up.
Uh,
uh,
what's her name?
The one who founded Rhode Island.
I mean,
we know the rock.
She was hiding behind which before,
and she got Scout Scout,
so they were tough warlike populations,
many of them.
So.
But the idea that just because we're
this many immigrant populations means we
have to continue being that way.
That's not a really a good argument.
Well,
it's not really an argument.
I'm just saying that we're essentially
founded by immigrants.
Not Saying we have to keep doing this is
what what we became,
but we were counted here from somewhere
else.
Everyone came here from somewhere else,
but we were founded by immigrants from
very specific places.
Now whether that's good or bad is a
separate issue,
but the idea that,
you know,
the founding fathers,
some of them were from Syria and some of
them were from then as well as not true.
Right.
They're mostly from Europe,
mostly specifically from British
speaking Europe.
Yeah,
that's true.
I mean,
but there were still plenty of
immigrants from Germany,
plenty of immigrants from Czechoslovakia
and Poland.
Poland was a huge immigrant population
early in the birth of the United States.
Right.
And they were thinking of making German
the official language because they hated
the British so much at one point.
And there's still a huge German speaking
populations,
but I think this argument is much more
complicated than people make it out to
be.
And the idea that like,
you know,
we're going to have complete open
borders without consequences is crazy.
And listen to my.
My mom still lives in a Russian
neighborhood in Brooklyn and it's a very
different place from the rest of New
York and I think that's a good thing,
but the idea that it's not a thing at
all.
It's false.
We're.
Yeah.
Well you can't say it's not a thing at
all.
So is the question whether or not the
consequences of open borders or worth
the.
The eventual gain some sort of
egalitarian society where everyone has
the opportunity to advance?
Well,
I think a lot of times when people are
on the left,
they don't think of costs.
They think if this is a good thing,
we don't have to worry about the cost
and it's the right thing to do.
And then when you bring up the cost,
like they're,
they're saying,
well you're a terrible person.
It's like sometimes the cost is worth
it,
but you have to acknowledge that there
is a cost.
Like we're seeing this right now with
transgender athletes when people are
like,
well what happens when someone who's
grown up mail is fighting someone who's
a female?
Like this is something we have to
grapple with.
It's like,
oh,
you're making up imaginary scenarios
like this is happening now,
like let's,
maybe it's the right thing to do,
but you still have to consider what are
the costs and radical inclusive
progressivism is,
they're just,
there are no differences.
There's no difference between gender.
There's no biological difference in
gender.
So there are so fundamentalist,
believe in creationism that God created
the world in seven days.
They have their own creation is in which
is that everyone was created equal and
remain.
So yeah.
Well,
it doesn't work when it comes to combat
sports for sure.
And that's like,
that is the,
that's where the rubber meets the road,
right.
Heel doesn't work in any aspect.
I mean,
if I grew up in,
uh,
in my,
my,
my dad's,
my parents are lawyers,
not that they are in real life.
I'm going to certainly have that
background and that advantage that other
people don't have.
Now that might be a good thing or it
might be a bad thing,
but it's a thing.
Yes,
it is a thing,
especially if you want to continue in
that business,
right?
Yeah.
While there's.
Yeah,
I mean the idea that we're all,
that we come from a,
an even position that we're all the
same.
Starting Line is pretty preposterous.
Correct.
Yeah.
The idea is just,
I mean,
if you want to,
like,
you can't fix that,
you can't change that.
That is what it is and you shouldn't
want to change it.
We should try to do is make the best
out of whatever hand you've been given.
Right?
Right.
I think that,
I think if you want to look at this
country and the real issues that we face
there,
you know,
they're multifaceted,
but one of the biggest ones is that
there are some areas of our country that
continue to,
um,
have people that are impoverished and in
crime ridden areas and these areas don't
ever change.
Right.
And that's one of our biggest problems.
I mean,
we're so concerned with all these
different issues and all sorts of valid
issues that are happening all over the
world,
but the issues of our own impoverished
communities that continue to be
impoverished south side of Chicago,
you know,
horrible areas of Texas are.
So there's some areas that just don't
get any better and they stay that way
generation after generation after
generation and they don't.
There's not enough interest in them in
terms of like broad mainstream focus
where they say,
look,
well we have to dedicate and allocate a
massive amount of resources to fixing
these inner cities.
And maybe just one project,
one flint,
Michigan style project where they say,
listen,
let's just dump and an x amount of time,
resources,
money and engineering,
figure out some way to fix these areas,
provide jobs,
make things more safe,
you know,
established community centers.
Do something and let's see if we can do
that and have it one case study one
impoverished city,
see if he could bring it up.
And then once you do,
move forward and try this in other
places I've always had like the best way
to make America stronger is to have less
losers.
Like what's the best way to have less
losers?
Well,
one one,
one way is to give people more of a
chance.
Give people.
Like if you grew up in suburban Los
Angeles and you live in some nice
neighborhood and you know,
studio city or something like that,
it's fairly safe and you have a much
higher likelihood of success than
someone who grows up in a crime ridden
drug filled environment where people are
constantly going to jail and those,
those sort of recurring cycles of
poverty and crime,
they happened generation after
generation after generation and some in
some cases,
like in Baltimore,
there's clear evidence of systematic
racism,
you know,
that literally people were stopped from
buying houses in certain areas.
Stop from moving into areas.
But in other areas it's like,
it's just almost like it does it itself
because he's right,
right.
And,
and they,
they,
I always have this litmus test for
people to find out if they're left wing
or right wing.
So people like to pretend I'm neither,
I'm both.
You ask them are some people better than
others?
And if you're right wing you're going to
say yes.
And if you're left wing,
you're going to start babbling a whole
speech better in like,
what does better mean?
Whatever you think.
In any sense of the word,
but it's sucking dicks as some people
who are better and some people are clear
that's right here,
but what causes that?
Some people are like,
no,
they just need to learn how to suck
dicks better.
Right?
Right.
And not everyone that I get,
I don't.
This is not a road on,
I know enough about to go down,
but dare you.
Okay.
Let's say play the flute,
right?
So the skin flute or regular flu.
Some people are better at it,
right?
Some people are better at math,
some people and that's going to be a
function of the mind,
you know,
and that's something that not everyone's
going to be able to equally good at.
And you have to start with that point
that we are born with different gifts,
um,
or we have different interests and we
pursue those specialty focus and
determination.
Yeah,
I mean there's certain things like
guitarists,
like there's,
there's no doubt about it.
This isn't like Stevie Ray Vaughan,
Jimi Hendrix,
Gary Clark Jr is people that have like
an exceptional ability to play
incredible music out of a guitar.
Does that,
what does that,
is that mean?
Where's that coming from?
Well,
it's also,
you and I are both self taught.
I'm sure you never get a major in
podcasting.
I never took an English course,
you know,
and,
and you've had many different careers
over your life.
So vi and that's just a function of the
self.
It's not a function of,
of uh,
the culture,
the,
it is,
it's also luck.
It's also being in the right place at
the right time.
It's also finding a job that exists that
fills my very unique personality and
making that job exist.
No one,
you know,
no one made me write this book.
I did a kickstarter,
I raised the 30 grand and I'm like,
now I'm going to do it myself.
So the publishing industry didn't know
what to make of it.
And how's it been?
How's it?
It's,
I mean,
just,
I got it.
I was the first one to have a,
a cspan book TV for a kickstarter book a
whole hour.
I mean,
I'm on all these different shows talking
about it because they didn't know it and
it's been a great success with as that
in that way it's got parallels I think
to podcasting.
Yes,
in that once you find something that
you're really passionate about this and
people realize that you're really
passionate about and you put so much
effort and focus into it,
they can see that in your work.
Yes,
and they appreciate that and I think
people are very much,
and this is another reason I load
cynicism.
People are drawn to earnestness,
they are drawn into passion and they are
drawn to sincerity and honesty and like
La,
La and we're hungry for it and we're
desperate for it and especially I think
increasingly young males because there's
so much eye rolling and there's so much
snark and all this other stuff which I
like,
but they like,
I want to be a better guy.
I want to be a smarter person.
One of the big lies I was told growing
up is that the jocks and the nerds hate
each other,
and when that was working with Matt
Hughes on his book and hanging out with
his fighter buddies,
it was a total mutual admiration
society.
There was no eyebrow raised,
there was no shit talking.
It was complete like,
wow,
you're a smart dude,
you know,
let me learn from you.
And I'm like,
wow,
you guys are athletes.
Let me learn from you.
And it's totally mutual respect.
It totally blew my mind.
Well,
one of the things about martial artists
is that there's everybody kind of.
I mean some people start off with a
certain physical talents and physical
gifts,
but when it comes to like technique and
ability,
you have to learn this,
you know,
and it's something that's very humbling
along the way.
And so they have this understanding that
hard work and focus and technique and
knowledge.
Yes.
All applied together equals results.
Yeah.
And they're awesome people and obviously
this is your world,
but I mean I've been.
I was blown away by these guys and had
such respect for them and I didn't think
I would.
I think it's changing.
I think perception of who fighters are
is changing and I think that's one of
the reasons why there's such a big blow
back when someone is like a thuggish
bully asshole ish sort of and that
these people aren't respected nearly as
much as someone like a George St Pierre
who is a gentleman,
right?
Conor mcgregor who was just this wild,
brilliant trash talker.
Right?
And these people like you,
you,
you could recognize that there some
significant mind games going on.
There's some real thinking and they're
not macho in the sense of they're not
posturing.
Like they don't need to stand up and be
like,
I can kick your ass like all the
fighters.
I knew if people go up to the bar and be
like,
you know,
I bet you I could kick your ass.
They'd be like,
I'm sure you can.
You know what I mean?
It still happens to these guys.
They have to walk away from fights all
the time,
but they do it gladly because they don't
have a chip.
Some of them do.
I'm sure you have a chip on the shoulder
of most of the ones I met.
None of them did and they would just be
like,
okay,
that's fine.
I saw it in person one night at a
nightclub in Vegas with some guy was
talking shit to chocolate Dell.
It was so ridiculous.
I mean I was just like,
what is this guy doing?
And then chocolate Dell just kind of
looked at him dead eyed and you know,
it said something to them and you see
the guy like saw his life passed before
his eyes and eventually realized came to
his senses and people pulled them away.
But I was like,
what is this fucking guy doing?
And it's so funny that one of the
scariest moments of my life when I was
working with he was on his book.
He's such a happy go lucky guy.
And then once I got an argument his face
changed and I'm like,
oh yeah,
that's who you are.
It,
I completely forgot that he killed her.
He's one of the greatest welterweight
champion.
It was like,
Oh yeah,
Shit.
Then I felt stupid to.
Well Matt was with first guy that
incorporated great wrestling with real
high level submissions.
When you see submitted Matt Frank Trigg,
when he submitted George St Pierre,
like he submitted George Saint Pierre
with very advanced move.
He hit him with a farsighted armbar.
George committed to a memorial but
didn't have control of Matt's body and
Matt hit the far side arm bar and spun
around on him.
I remember watching that was for.
It was at 4:59 of the first round.
I believe he had one second to go and
George tapping really quick.
I don't remember what time it was,
but I remember that just a brilliant
move.
He said he,
when he was starting out was he was
like,
I know I'm strong and I'm a good
wrestler.
I got to learn technique or else it's
going to be used against me.
So it was very,
very strategic with his approach.
He really wasn't a big factor in that
whole camp.
That miletich fighting system camp was
Jeremy Horn who was like really like
kind of a nerdy guy and a lot of.
He's not a bully type guy at all,
not a very strong guy,
not a freak athlete,
but had more than a hundred and 50
professional fights and one a shit ton
of them and was really.
It was the first guy to beat chocolate.
They'll put them to sleep from the
bottom with an arm triangle from the
bottom because he was just a brilliant
tactician and just very good at staying
calm.
Very good at figuring out like it was
all technique.
Jeremy was all technique and still is.
Yeah.
I never met you.
I met,
always spoke extremely highly of.
He's a great guy and all those people
and he's a super polite,
really kindhearted guy who just happens
to be a trained killer.
Right.
A lot of these guys that's not super
polite,
but he is.
He's very polite.
You don't think he's super blessed.
So the thing with that,
I mean I can't say enough good things
about him,
like having been friends with him and
his family.
To this day I still go out to
hillsborough to visit them,
has changed my life so profoundly,
but he would.
Matt Hughes meets you.
He'll be making fun of you and people
have them on a pedestal so they won't
respond back and he looks like an
asshole.
So when I first got the project,
this is a great story.
I was on the phone with his manager and
his manager goes,
Matt's got a twin brother and when they
start messing with you,
you just got to stand there and take it
until they're tired.
And I thought to myself,
Nigga,
I'm from Brooklyn,
we don't play that shit.
I swear to God as much as I thought it,
I thought it.
And then I think racist words to
yourself during.
I'm thinking one now.
So I meet Matt and he starts with me and
I hit him back hard and he loved it.
He loves being the butt of a joke
because he wants to be a regular guy.
He hates being on a pedestal.
He hates being.
I'm the world champion.
He's those normal dude and I think it
kind of bothers him that people won't
make fun of him back.
Well,
that's sort of fight gym culture though.
Everybody makes fun of it.
It's the.
But they're scared to make fun of him
because it's all my God Matt Hughes and
it's like,
no,
no.
Please hit me.
Like he's always cackling and laugh,
you know,
as the best instagram page.
Who?
Derrick Lewis,
Derek,
the beast,
Lewis he's got were just knocked out.
Travis Brown is one of the top
heavyweights contenders.
His fucking instagram is whole Arius.
What?
Hilarie he just finds the most fucked up
shit online and puts it on his instagram
page.
Like one of them was a picture of a girl
with like 15 hot dogs and her mouth and
it said something like,
don't worry about it.
These guys are all just like brothers to
me.
We're just going to hang out.
What do you remember?
Forrest Griffin for Halloween with
supergirl,
supergirl with the crop top and he
captioned it.
Does this make me look gay?
And he's like,
how about.
No,
it was hilarious.
Well,
that's problematic.
Left.
Yeah,
I mean these guys,
look,
there's a lot of gallows humor and a lot
of like really funny guys that are
involved in like these fight gems.
Oh yeah.
It's because they're dealing with such
incredible stress levels that they need
some sort of a blow off valve.
Right.
You know,
Derrick Lewis is one of the top
heavyweight cage fighting fighters on
the planet earth.
I mean,
he's one of the best in the UFC right
now.
He's just knocked out.
Travis Browne,
knocked him out cold and recovered from
a rough first round,
got hurt,
came back and knocked him out.
So his instagram just like,
you would think that he'd be like this
crazy psychopaths running hills and
screaming into the night,
you know,
like I remember when I was a kid,
um,
there was a video of Mostafa Ham show
versus Marvin Hagler.
They will do it showing this promo clip
and they were,
I lived in Boston and Hagler was a
Boston guy was from brockton and he used
to train in the Cape because it was
freezing cold in the winter and they'd
have him running these sand dudes in the
renter.
And while he's running them,
he was screaming war and Hagler was
terrifying because he was just ripped
and muscular and he had a bald head and
he just was a destroyer.
And so that was my idea of like what a
fighter is like a daily,
like this solemn.
Right,
you know,
character clowns in the best possible
way.
Yeah.
A lot of them are very,
very funny and it just and appreciate,
even if they're not funded,
the appreciate a good sense of humor.
A lot of joking around for breezy over
doom jokes around a lot.
He's pretty funny.
Yeah.
There's a lot of them that are like
that.
It's interesting.
You know.
And then when people are too serious and
they lose,
that's when the public goes after them.
Right?
Like Ronda Rousey.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Like I can beat anyone on earth,
man.
When the public one after her boy woo
dark.
And Matt always said,
if you're not losing,
you're not fighting the right people.
Well,
it's true.
Yeah.
I mean,
unless you're some fucking freak of
athleticism and some top of the food
chain,
Roy Jones Jr type character.
And there's always gonna be those guys
just go,
there's always outliers,
right?
Who essentially their bar movers,
like they change expectations.
Like there was expectations for
performances inside the UFC.
And then there was Anderson Silva and
then Anderson Silva came along and
everybody went,
okay,
well we now we know that's possible.
But were you,
were you calling the fight when he broke
his shin?
Yes.
What was that like in real life to see?
So second time I've seen that first time
I saw it was Corey Hill broke his shin.
And um,
I,
I had to scream at the referee that time
because the referee didn't realize it
had happened.
Oh my God.
And so,
uh,
because he was in a different position,
the referee was not in a position to
see.
And then corey went down and um,
I forget his name,
I know the dude,
I'm sorry.
But when his opponent was attacking him,
the referee hadn't realized that core
his leg,
it's snapped in half yet.
So I'm fucking screaming.
I took my headphones off and I stood up
and I'm screaming,
stop.
The fight stopped the fight.
And it was,
did they stop it?
They heard,
you know,
I think he figured it out.
I don't know if it helped I,
but I just couldn't help it.
I just had to jump up.
It means it was.
I'd only seen it on film before.
I've never seen anybody's leg snap like
that in real life.
Right.
And it's seen in a few times and
kickboxing match.
Oh,
you had a lot live only on video.
And it's like,
I can't believe the human body can do
that.
I knew I could do it.
I've seen it happen a few times.
It happened to one of the best kick
boxers in the world.
Tyrone spong just a couple of years ago.
And it essentially shut his kickboxing
career now.
He was fighting go.
Saki was also one of the best kickbox is
in the world.
And go checked one of his kicks and
tyrone's leg just act like a joint.
Yeah.
And spong is just elite of the elite.
He's one of the.
It was like these two guys,
tyrone spong and go con sock.
It was like a world class,
kickboxing fight where the whole
kickboxing community,
like people that are like myself,
there are big fans were like,
whoo,
here we go.
Here we go and see it.
And like that there.
When you had the Anderson one was very
unfortunate,
but you know that they think he broke
his leg actually with a kick earlier in
that round.
Oh yeah.
It was hurting him apparently already.
And then he threw that and it just
snapped in half so it might have been
already compromised by a similar
situation.
And then that one maybe like a hairline
fracture and that one just snapped it
all in half that I couldn't handle that.
It's rough.
It's a rough game,
man.
Corey Hill,
the guy,
the first guy that had happened to,
he's dead now.
He died.
I don't remember what he died of,
but he died real young.
Yeah,
there's Corey Hill.
Dale Heart.
Yeah,
that's who it is.
Yeah.
That was a rough,
rough fucking fight to watch men seat
snap in half like that.
So it's only happened twice in the UFC
in that way.
But we've had,
you know,
we've had a significant number of broken
bones,
like Frank Mir snapped Tim Silvia's arm
and half.
That was pretty fucked up.
I'd met Tim.
He was a good guy.
He's a good guy.
Quiet guy.
Yeah.
He's,
you know,
he's a guy that just didn't have like a
lot of athletic talent,
right?
Just hard work,
determination and a little bit of
steroids and a great coach.
Yeah.
And Pat Miletich,
she's like,
well,
let's work with what I have and I'm
going to make you a champion.
That's what you did back in the day,
man,
when he fought Rico Rodriguez.
And back in the day when Mexicans
supplements were a lot easier to get
away with Tim.
Sylvia was a fucking destroyer.
Tim Silvia.
He missed like that era was the era of
the guys who fought in pride,
the wild West era where you could just
kind of do whatever the fuck you want.
If Sylvia existed in that era,
just Jesus Christ,
man,
he might've been one of the best at
best.
Like if you go back to like go see if
you can find Tim Silvia versus Rico
Rodriguez.
That's when he won the title dude.
He was a fucking destroyed.
He had to cut weight to make to 65.
He was fucking 70 feet tall,
jacked.
And this was an Tim Silvia was people
think of Tim Silvia.
They think of Tim Silvia being
overweight when he fought rate mercery
got knocked out with one punch.
You in the early days of Tim.
Sylvia,
when he was on top of his game,
he was fucking terrifying.
That's.
See if you can find like a better photo
of it though.
Like you could see like how fucking huge
was.
Yeah,
there he is right there.
He was jacked and so big.
That was when he fought cabbage.
Beat the fuck out of cattle.
I was backstage when he fought randy and
remember randy got him knocked out
within like 20 seconds.
He had him on the ground,
went through a crazy punch and branded
it and tim didn't see coming.
It was.
It was insane.
Yeah.
Well,
Tim was friends with Randy,
so he was really shocked that a randy
wanted to fight him in the first place
and that was when randy was a light
heavyweight.
Tim was heavyweight and randy hit him
with a fake inside leg kick and a giant
bottle of an overhand right right away
and tim didn't even know what the fuck
happened.
He was out on his feet and he came back
to that locker room is I was all
swollen.
She was like,
Holy Shit.
I just saw you two minutes ago.
It was crazy.
That's the fight game.
Yeah.
It's a fight game.
Tim Silvia doesn't get enough love.
It really doesn't.
Now I see him now.
Like it's just enormous.
Three hundred 71 pounds.
Yeah.
Is this a recent one?
When is this from it.
I don't think he's fighting anymore.
He's.
He does a lot of bowhunting now.
I think that's what he does with
medically unfit to two years ago,
ruled medically unfit to compete and
reality fighting because it was 371
pounds.
See?
That was.
That's.
That's crazy.
That means he gained a hundred 10 pounds
from the time he was in his prime.
He says,
no,
it's not good.
Not good,
but when he was at his best,
he's a very under appreciated
heavyweight.
No,
I just think I hope I people being
friends with these people has helped me
out so much in regular life and they
talk about a lot how this carries over
and it really,
really does.
The way they carry themselves,
the way they think.
Like Matt always said,
for every move there's a counter for
every counter,
there's a counter and that's the kind of
thing where like if you're going to move
someone in your career,
you're going to have to leave some blank
exposed and you have to become less risk
averse and make that shot and sometimes
you're not gonna make that shot,
but you still have to go for it.
Just because you see the dangerous
doesn't mean there's always going to be
dangerous.
You have to fucking go for it.
Yeah.
There's definitely some lessons to be
learned from all martial arts training
that what I've always said is this.
Something that I learned from my
earliest taekwondo instructor was the
taekwondo and all martial arts are
essentially a veil of vehicle for human
potential.
Devo,
developing your human potential and that
these difficult things that you do,
if you can overcome them,
you'll find lessons in those that you
could apply to business.
Personal relationships.
Like anything life throws at you.
Oh yeah.
And,
and also,
uh,
there's a North Korean story.
We're in 1978,
I think there were,
there in the DMZ,
the border between north and South Korea
and the Americans wanted to chop down a
tree or to prune it.
And the North Koreans took their ax and
chop them up and killed them.
That acs is on display now in North
Korea.
I saw it chopped up the Americans,
but they,
they,
they boast that they use taekwondo dell
to,
to conquer these greater numbers of
Americans because it's a Korean martial
art.
Oh,
right.
They did it because they're like,
you're not chopping down this tree fund.
So they killed them because they wanted
to chop down a tree and they Americans
launched Operation Paul Bunyan and came
back with like 200 guys and carriers.
We look at job at that,
this trade and is,
did they left the stump to be like,
fuck you.
America?
Yeah.
Um,
I think the real issue with fighters is
making sure that they recognize that
father time is real and that the
expiration date is real and that there's
only a certain amount of punishment.
The physical frame,
your meat vehicle that you're carrying
through this life can endure.
And then after awhile it's downhill.
Well,
you know what,
that hit close to home for me because I
always wanted to have abs,
right?
And let's not laugh.
And Joe Rogan,
I work with my coach Dick Talents and
he's like,
I can get you to abs.
He got me to abs.
You got it.
ABS.
Ceos.
What's the.
Yeah.
I wrote an article about how getting out
changed my life.
You.
Here's the spoiler was zero positive
outcome.
I put,
I put the APP,
vote on tinder.
No one fucking cared,
but now I have to maintain them or else
I'm going to be the men and decline and
I'm going to be scared.
I'm losing my peak,
you know,
so that's something that every guy goes
through.
So now I'm in this fucking trap of
having to stick by this fucking regimen.
Okay,
well I can help you right there.
How's that starts?
The way you're looking at it,
you're looking at it like it's trap
expectations that must be maintained,
right?
That's just a mind trap.
Will have in it.
Just not.
You know,
you're not.
You could instead look only towards
always improving and don't ever think of
it as a trap.
Think of it as a perpetual life like
path.
Oh sure I am improving at.
The point is I can't be like this.
Body fat can increase a certain policy.
That's like what people do like you hear
about that.
When people become famous,
like when they become famous or become
wealthy,
they get panicky and they want to cling
to isolate and insulate themselves.
They lose what got them.
They become risk averse.
They lose what got them to the dance in
the first place.
My abs did not get me to any dance.
They Florida.
They should.
Well,
they showed them to the right people.
You're a single guy.
I am a desperate yes.
Desperately.
Single Guy.
Pull up that shirt and right in front of
that camera going to be preaching mamas
to send you.
Send some pussy or way you could fill up
the photo that I've already had to start
tanning I.
I had to.
Yeah,
it's been required of you because I do a
lot of TV and my body fat was low enough
that I looked holocaust,
the unscreened.
Oh Jesus.
So your body fat.
It's low enough that I looked sick and
like my family,
I didn't really speak to thought I was
literally starving.
Cool.
What are you eating?
Nothing.
Oh,
look at that dude.
You're good.
That's very good.
It's pretty good,
dude.
That's good.
Yeah.
I think you're gonna.
Get some pussy now.
I think so.
He's drinking monster energy drink.
Kind of maintained his fucking
metabolome monster on the podcast.
Monster in the bedroom.
This.
Oh,
you son of a bitch.
I just mean it like choking.
That's the sugar stuff.
Sugar,
sugar freestyle with low sugar,
low carb,
low carb.
Scammy.
Joe.
It was a little bit of sugar,
right?
It's 10 calories for the can.
I mean 10 grams or calories.
Ten grams of sugar.
10,
25 calories for the can.
Oh,
that's not bad.
Yeah.
There's nothing.
There's seven grams of carbs.
Those things are tasty.
They're a little too tasty.
I can't drink those.
That's a sponsor of the UFC,
so they always had them laying around
and some.
So sometimes I'll drink one during a
broadcast,
but then you have to fucking pee.
The problem is that stuff runs through
you fast.
Thanks for telling me that.
As I'm sitting here initially.
I know on the stomach.
Hang in there.
I can hang in there.
It's 4:00.
I'm thinking we're going to go for
another like 15 minutes.
Perfect.
Really?
Do we just.
Wow.
Got.
We've got to do this format.
This Sean,
you're a Brooklyn guy.
You live in New York.
I Love Brooklyn.
Yes.
How long are you gonna?
Be on here for A.
I just left for a couple of days.
Oh,
beautiful.
Yeah.
You got any plans?
What are you gonna do when you're out
here and hanging out with my buddy matt,
who you know,
he's an internet
personality.
I'm just going to do just some work and
that's it.
Just experienced life on the west coast.
I'm not an la fan to know what bothers
you about.
There's a certain corruption about it.
Corruption.
Yeah.
I feel like there's a veneer of sunshine
and stability,
but underneath that there's a lot of a
fakeness and and nastiness and I new
Yorkers were more direct and more
surface.
That's interesting.
Fakeness and nastiness.
How so?
Meaning like when I meet people in La
and they're like,
Oh,
you're an author.
Like I'm sorry I haven't heard any of
your books.
It's like,
why the fuck are you?
Sorry,
I'm nobody.
Do you know what I mean?
Like that kind of thing.
So they don't.
They're scared of offending someone in
case that might be important
or it's like we should definitely grab
lunch,
meaning good to see you,
but it doesn't mean literally we should
grab lunch.
It's all these codes that you could find
a losers like that New York to pull.
I'm not hanging out with them.
I guess they met the wrong people in la.
Are you meeting them then?
What do you mean?
In New York?
Well,
no,
you're generalizing like you're
generalizing these people that you're
meeting that they're worried about
offending you.
It's it.
It's happened enough that it's part of
the culture here.
It's not just one data point Joe Rogan
and it's just like.
It's jarring to me.
I'm not used to it from Brooklyn.
You're a big fan of that data point
line.
I,
yeah,
I mean,
but you're limited data points and how
many people you meet.
How often are you here?
Twenty 4 million,
25.
All of them.
How often do you here?
For like once a year.
Yeah.
I think the thing about La is there's
pockets of humanity,
like these voices of interesting people
and I,
I,
I'm a cultivator of interesting people.
I like to like when I find them,
I cleaned to them.
The problem is yes,
that's my approach.
There's always someone that's trying to
get into that group.
That's not right.
Yes.
Yeah.
Entry Ism.
And then you know,
and that they bring their crew and it's
been a.
it's infected.
Yeah.
It becomes an issue and especially
amongst comedians becomes an issue.
Oh God,
they want to work with you and do shows
with you and stuff like that.
And you're like,
hey.
The same happened.
And I,
I,
I did two books with dl Hughley who's
also an amazingly wonderful person and I
didn't see that much around him.
Like he hangs with their various crew.
He's very smart,
very smart.
I learned a lot from him.
He's not suffering any fools.
No,
exactly.
And it's also really fun being the white
guy with a group of black people going
to a club or something like that.
And then when she use the n word I,
it's in the chapter in the first book
about it.
Which book that I did two books with
him.
The first call I want you to shut the
fuck up.
And he said,
Uncle Sam on the cover.
That's the book I want you to shut the
fuck up.
That is hilarious.
Title for a book.
The second one's called black man.
White House.
I came up with both those titles and
their and I want you to shut the fuck up
as a very good time.
I want you to shut the fuck up.
He's Uncle Sam on the kind of.
Yeah,
I learned a lot from him.
Also.
Just a great,
great guy.
Yeah,
he's a good dude.
He's a decent guy.
Like I'm sure you know all the comedians
and who were the assholes behind the
scenes and who aren't and don't think
anyone thinks badly of him.
He's very.
Whereas this hardness sleeve.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Deal that well.
I've run into him a few times and had
good conversations with him and he's
always been very nice,
but you're right.
I don't ever hear bad things.
He's a mench.
A mench is interesting.
I want to know is that I have.
I actually have a blowup of that firm.
We did a book signing and he signed it
to me over my instructions to my Nigga
Michael Nicholas piece pimping.
It's hanging up in the house.
Isn't that great?
There's my name,
little desk.
Audacity of dopes is ruining America.
That's hilarious.
I love how you can say fuck,
as long as you put it in like a pound
sign for the you will.
They wanted a curse because there was a
book called go the fuck to sleep,
which did huge.
So they're like,
okay,
we need a curse in the title.
I'm like,
all right,
so offensive to me that you can cover up
one letter and everybody's like,
okay,
we're good.
Yeah,
no my friends,
new book's going to call fuck whales.
Like fuck whales and all these other
shit.
You know an f f has a pound signs like,
oh well this is spot and I'll put this
on the shelf in the supermarket.
Isn't it funny?
Yeah.
You could just do that.
Such child.
No language has changed because we used
to not be able to say fuck.
And now we can't say the n word,
but it's when we were kids it was,
fuck.
That was the problem.
You'd never seen writing ever while you
did.
Did Archie Bunker's say the n word on
all in the family?
He must have.
I would imagine he did.
I know that a Fred Redd Foxx did redd
foxx did on Sanford and sons because I
remember I remember him saying it about
like,
I think it was like a jury.
I think it was like during a trial or
something like that.
I'm trying to remember what the line
was,
but it was.
He said the last time I saw this many
niggers was in a Tarzan movie and I'm
like,
fuck,
did they put that on tv?
But it was a different world and it was
Red Fox who's by the way,
like almost like,
I mean him and Richard Pryor.
We're like one of two of the most
important figures of like black standup
comedy of any standup comedy.
Yeah,
for sure.
I mean the comedians are the ones who
are always pushing the envelope and
that's their job and it enrages me when
people are trying to.
That's not fun.
I have my next book.
I have this whole chapter about that's
not funny.
That's like I knew a North Korean
refugee and he would,
he went to high school here and he'd be
hanging out with his friends and they'd
be like,
Hey,
remember when we were kids there was
pokemon.
He'd be like,
yeah,
except instead of Pokemon,
I watched my debts starve to death along
with most of my village.
So you have that dark sense of humor.
He joked around about that because you
have to,
like,
you come from that culture.
If you don't laugh,
you're not going to be able to kind of
deal with it.
So you're going to tell him he can't
joke about starbuck,
his starving family.
Who the fuck are you?
Why did that guy get out?
Uh,
you,
he escaped to China.
He was basically a slave.
A woman kind of found him.
She was a Christian.
There's a bit Christian population in
China and then it's a whole process.
Wow.
How do you escape the China?
Did he bribed the guards in the middle?
During the day?
He just crossed the Tumen River and they
just happen not to see him,
but he's a kid.
How old was he?
I mean,
he was under 16 and over 11,
somewhere in that range.
So when you,
when someone from your family escapes,
your whole family's punished.
So the great leader,
Kim Il Sung said class enemies must be
exterminated.
Two,
three generations.
So in America,
when people like Rick Santorum say the
families,
the basic unit of society unit means
that which can't be subdivided further.
They put that into practice.
So if someone from your family,
there's something wrong,
three generations are punished.
So if someone escapes,
that's going to be really bad for use.
They often get fake.
They bribed someone to get a fake death
certificate.
Yeah.
So someone escapes your parents and then
grandparents were kids or siblings,
kids or anybody.
Whoever the fuck can be around is
imprisoned or deported to some
countryside.
Like if you're in Pyongyang,
there's something called Sung Monday,
have a caste system,
right?
Which has three layers,
which is how loyal you are to the
government and that determines where you
can live in the country and what your
job could be.
So you're not allowed to step foot in
the capital city unless you're loyal to
the regime.
So what happens is if you're from
Pyongyang and you defect,
your family's going to get sent to Lex
bumble,
fuck,
you know,
who knows?
And now you've got to raise rice and
anyone from North Korea who's an
ambassador,
they have family back there.
So make sure that you don't make any
mistakes and try to stay in that
country.
Yes,
they have layers upon layers of control.
They're brilliant at it.
It's horrific,
but brilliant,
right?
Yes.
Yeah,
they're,
I mean these are really the supermind
master,
the super villains of our time,
horrific and its execution,
but brilliant.
And it's the whole master plan of it.
Other things,
do they tell people don't wear ripped
jeans to the DMZ because North Korea
takes these photos and shows US citizens
go look before the rest of the country,
rest of the world dressed in rags.
Wow,
that's a brilliant,
brilliant.
It's absolutely brilliant.
It is Alaris that were so wealthy in
America that we buy jeans that are
already scratched up or like acid,
like let's just put acid on your genes.
All right,
that's fine.
I was watching this video online about
how they make those,
uh,
what's the word that they use for
distress is stress where they were
taking like a sander blasting and she's
like,
what the fuck are we doing?
I went into this whole gene,
a phase.
I got 30 pairs because I thought it was
just.
I started collecting them and then I
got.
The point is when they're raw,
you wear them,
the ink breaks down and they distress in
their own.
They get these cool fades and I wore my
best pair to like this fancy denim store
in La and no one praise me.
And I'm like,
fuck you in this subculture.
And I know one praised you upset.
Yeah.
At the last parent earth have these
persimmon died.
You know,
Japanese do at the time.
This is like two years ago,
they were cocky sheebu man.
What does that hockey she boo.
It's unripened persimmon die.
I don't know what that is.
That person is a person that a person is
a fruit,
right?
Right.
So they take the unripened juice,
they soak the clothing in it and it
becomes this pinkish Orange Hue.
And this co company,
sugarcane made jeans that color and they
looked pinkish orange,
you and they look sick.
They look amazing.
I know what you're single.
Is that right?
Because that'll just.
That'll show the abs personal fucking
stained
genes that you're worried about being
praised for.
That was about the ones that call me.
I've got Sour Samurai jeans,
Khakis.
Shubie died 24 ounce cocktail Shubu.
Sorry.
I got the sugar cane.
One 24 ounce.
I liked how they weigh them.
Like who gives a fuck how much there was
that?
The heavier the gene,
the better.
The fades.
A interesting.
Yeah.
Huh.
Okay.
See those kinds of genes don't interest
me because they.
They seem like it's hard to move around
them.
No.
Well that's when you break them down.
That's the whole point.
Yeah.
But they're not like,
like,
you know what?
These are right here.
These are barbell jeans.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
I know about those.
Yeah.
They stretch for big quads.
Do these are like fucking sweatpants,
man.
Throw head kicks.
Wearing these,
these.
I like these.
And there's another company called Mott
and bow.
They make them and they're like a little
bit thicker.
They a more expensive pair of jeans,
but it has the same sort of stretch
flexy thing.
That's the kind of Shit I liked it.
Well,
the company I like called naked and
famous,
they're Canadian.
They have genes that change colors.
He knows naked and famous.
They've got A.
I've got a fuck ton of them,
but they don't.
They're not salmon colored Khaki Shubu
fucking.
That's true.
And that looks like sugar cubes are
ridiculous.
I've got the mud dive.
I got 30 pairs.
Man.
I just love the fact that you were
bummed out that nobody prays.
You have no idea.
It's so honest though.
It's so ridiculous.
That was the Khaki Shiva.
There was no praise that.
Who would know the guy at the denim
stores should fucking know.
That's the one guy who should know
Jamie,
Jamie.
Whereas Kanye West sneakers.
That's not.
That's not the whole.
That's a whole different vibe.
That's basic shit.
No,
no,
no.
This is a little.
It is.
Come on.
I like the hipster stuff.
Shit.
I don't have the actual crazies that are
like 5,080.
Oh,
come on.
They have 5,000,
$8,000 dollars wants to make.
I'm not a fan.
Not a fan either.
You've got a real collector.
Gets the stuff that's not that expensive
but is really unique and khaki.
Shibu is cocky shape.
Do you still wear them or you just
praise?
I cry and I was gonna Ram today and I'm
like,
am I gonna wear today?
Nobody brought them up.
I know.
Set I.
I navy.
But you don't seem like a Fashionista.
You don't seem like the guys who made
the shirt you're wearing,
man.
It's got epilepsy.
Oh,
it's good for ugly people.
Then you're saying you're saying people
who are going to end up,
you know how like board games or like
ages five and up.
So this is ugly and up.
Oh,
I get it.
Yeah.
I mean it's not a terrible shirt but
it's,
you know.
I mean if you're into really being
praised for your clothes,
I wouldn't imagine that would be your
best choice.
Well,
I was going to wear a suit.
I wear suits on,
on Fox all the time and I'm probably one
of the best dressed people network.
Do you enjoy being on Fox?
I love it.
Really?
Oh,
I love it.
Why?
Because I get to be the same thing that
gets me in trouble at parties and I'm
rewarded for it.
What is the thing that gets you in
trouble at parties?
Vicious?
Uh,
if this rating denigrating
all these things,
like the nasty.
It's so fun.
What do you,
why do you like doing that?
Because I think there's a lot of
horrible people and they need to be
called out on their bullshit and I'm in
a position to do it.
What kind of arguments do you have on
file?
I've never seen you on Fox for.
Well,
I don't watch too much.
It's fine.
I just,
I,
it's just like if I'm talking about
politicians,
I always make it a point to be as
denigrating and humiliate and to them
personally as possible.
But when you're talking to them
personally,
not personally,
but we're talking about them.
Whatever the issue is.
I'm not usually in paddle actual
politicians.
I was on with John Bolton ones,
which was weird,
but I mean I go,
I'm out.
I'm shopping for blood,
you know,
with these types,
someone's got to be Batman and punching
these people in the face metaphorically.
Metaphorically.
Yeah.
So you enjoy it because it gives you an
opportunity to intervene.
Yeah,
send a message home to will it to be
mean.
Which I'm good at,
but it's not culturally socially
acceptable.
This is why I don't drink because you're
afraid you're going to be more mean.
I got meaner.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
And the thing is I'm really funny for
people who just listen to you.
You gave me like the sideways looking
through your eyebrows.
Oh yeah.
But that's the thing like my,
my,
my mouth is very quick so I'll have that
good line and the next day I'm like,
that person's going to feel like shit
and I shouldn't have said it.
Oh yeah.
And that they don't deserve that at a
party.
But you're meant it.
At the time I met the joke,
it came out.
I mean the joke landed.
Well,
that's the thing about hanging out with
comedians to like,
you know,
a lot of comics that I know,
but you can kind of get away with that,
like you could shit on a comic and if
it's funny they'll laugh with you,
but if it's a regular person,
especially a female,
you don't want to do that.
They don't deserve it at all and I feel
guilty for a long time and I shouldn't
feel guilty.
I should feel guilty,
especially if they're not used to it.
Yeah.
And especially if they come at you
thinking,
oh my friends tell me I'm funny,
and it's just like,
well you started the wrong fucking war.
Yeah.
Maybe they could make fun of your genes
and it really hurt you.
They wouldn't have those sheebu.
They wouldn't have the language to do so
they wouldn't know the language.
Shibu is it?
Was it that obscure?
Well,
ted,
you heard of it.
I don't know anything man.
You don't even know the rules to
basketball.
Khaki.
She was.
The reason why those jeans are awesome
is because they're obscure.
Oh,
that's one of those guys.
Yeah,
things rare things are good.
One hundred percent,
a hundred percent.
Are you a car guy?
You're interested in?
I don't know how to drive.
Because you're in New York City.
Yeah.
That's weird.
But at like rare plants.
Rare fish or you're just in a rare shit.
I like having stuff that's only your own
because when everyone puts their sticky
fingers on it,
it ruins it.
So like if you really like something,
be fine.
Other people like it as well and become
popular.
You get upset.
Hell on earth.
Are you one of those dudes that gets
bombed out with a bang?
It's popular.
It's the worst thing ever.
It's the worst thing.
It hurts me physically.
It doesn't really.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It's so silly though.
They're silly because then stupid people
are liking what you like and then you've
got a question.
Your choices.
That's stupid.
People like all sorts of stuff.
That's awesome.
But if.
Yeah,
but incorrectly,
they like it for the wrong reasons.
What about ice cream with have stupid
people like chocolate ice.
You can calculate what
the hell it can kind of.
Crazy person.
Are you that you don't like chocolate?
No.
My favorite ice cream is pink,
is pink bubblegum from Baskin Robbins
and I fucking had to go to every baskin
Robbins and Manhattan trying to find it
every year.
And it drives me crazy.
I go on my instagram,
I finally found it.
Yeah,
but there's nothing wrong with chocolate
like you don't like chocolate ice cream.
Chocolate ice cream was God damn
delicious.
Chuck Haagen,
daas chocolate,
a Haagen Daz.
Ooh,
la La.
Look at Ms Dot Nancy is
important.
We got along so well their whole foods.
So we started talking about an ice
cream.
I'm so fancy.
I eat Haagen,
Daz fucking supermarket in the country.
That's your baskin robbins.
Say Chocolate guy.
Haagen Daz with your perrier.
Mr Rogan.
I enjoy it at like a sparkling water.
So it gives you a little bit of flavor,
but you don't like the person in juice.
Um,
well,
your genes are pink.
They're not paying salmon
pink for people who are struggling with
their gait thoughts.
I said salmon is the struggle and
realize that,
right?
My struggle.
You go over someone's house and they
have salmon code sheets.
You'd be like,
oh,
I don't have salmon colored sheets.
I have lavender.
I'm kidding.
Sad,
sad,
sad.
Everything black.
The whole house,
including the wallpaper.
I don't have wallpaper.
No.
I think wallpaper is super gay.
Wallpapers.
Gay.
You don't think so?
Um,
I've never thought about it.
I think the first time I've ever
entertained that thought and my years in
this planet,
whether or not wallpapered have anything
to do with your sexual proclivities,
I think it's all that designery stuff.
Oh,
okay.
Like the house,
it's over designed.
It's like,
well,
what's up with this dude?
Some people will just really into design
like chains.
Well,
not anymore.
It's just so critical.
Not other people's weird shit,
but your own weird shit.
You just like you see through a filter
and loving put on blast.
No,
it's fascinating.
And it'd be both.
Yes.
It definitely can be.
You can live your life through these
contradictions.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's a fun life to live.
Yeah,
sure.
There's nothing wrong to blame me for
getting upset that no one is praising my
khaki pants.
Yes.
Again,
because I see that you care.
Like I've never wanted someone to praise
me for a piece of clothing that I wore,
but maybe since I was like 12 and I had
a kiss tee shirt on,
I searched so long for them and I got
the last pair on earth.
Oh my God.
That's a problem in and of itself.
They even went looking for those fucking
salmon disastrous jeans.
I got 29 other bears that you'd approve
of.
I got the stainless steel ones.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
You have stainless steel pants?
Yeah.
How's that work?
It's sustaining steel.
A cotton weave.
Who makes sense?
Naked and famous.
They were like 250 pairs made and I got
them.
What does it look like?
It's just wrinkly.
The.
It's as if you're wearing wet jeans,
but they're dry.
That's how it feels like it's stiff,
but why do they call it stainless steel?
Because the weave is part 10 percent
stainless steel.
Ninety percent cotton or the chaperone
heavy?
No,
they're not that heavy,
but they're aren't weird.
Yeah.
Pull those up.
Jamie stainless steel naked and famous
jeans.
Yeah.
That's so odd.
This is like the opposite of barbell
jeans.
Yes.
Like that.
You can't throw kicks in them.
That's right.
And it's was hard to walk in at first
because you're walking a robot
and I actually more than once to the
airport and I got scared.
I'm like,
Oh fuck.
Oh,
metal detector.
They don't detect metal anymore.
I have those to the pornography pants.
Pornography.
The inside cuff is a vintage
pornography.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
I wonder if you can control with those.
Like it just looks like newsprint of Qa.
There's the stainless steel wants to the
right of the pinup.
Yeah,
those are stainless steel ones.
Yeah.
So they're just heavy.
They're stiff.
They're not actually that heavy.
Huh.
Interesting.
So like stainless steel thread.
So it's just like a novelty.
There is no benefit to but they just
look at the.
The wrinkling looks very cool.
The puckering to the fabric.
You're an interesting guy.
Michael is a euphemism,
you know,
I said that to Jamie for the show.
So I said something about being
interesting and that always means
something else.
No,
you're an interesting guy.
You are an interesting guy.
Like I mean it in the most sincere way,
but that word can have many
connotations.
It can but not.
It's not how I'm reading it.
Okay.
Isn't that what's important?
Intent,
right?
Yes.
One hundred percent intent.
So we should wrap this up,
but uh,
I really appreciate you coming here.
I really appreciate having a
conversation with you and finding out
about your weird tastes,
but you're a good dude man.
You're a funny guy and a very smart guy.
And your book,
dear reader is available pretty much
everywhere,
right?
Amazon,
Amazon.
Are Now an audio?
Yeah,
we just did the audio.
It was amazing.
Beautiful.
Did you do it?
No,
I got a guy in my voice is awful for it,
but I got it.
Great.
But the guy who did it was like hearing
the voice of the narrator in my head and
I almost cried because it was like a
magical moment.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
And um,
that's it.
So your twitter.
Michael Mouse.
Yes sir.
Anything else?
That's it.
Thanks brother.
Appreciate it man.
It was a lot of fun.
It's a lot of fun.
Michael Mouse.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we'll be back tomorrow with.
What's it
everlast?
Yes.
Tomorrow.
Everlasting.
And then who else we got somebody else
got this week.
Tom Papa's here.
What's that?
Oh,
Robert Sapolsky to.
Yeah,
we've got a good week folks,
so we'll see you soon.
Alright,
bye.
Bye.